Die Klänge sind bekannt. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Ihr seid bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio. Das waren wie immer Kraftwerke am Anfang. Vielleicht habt ihr es ja gesehen am Wochenende beim Hurricane oder beim Southside Festival. Es muss fürchterlich geregnet haben. Das zumindest sind die Informationen, die so durchs Netz gehen und die auch getwittert wohnen. Und damit sind wir beim Thema der heutigen Sendung. Huckel ist bei uns, Tim ist bei uns. Herzlich willkommen Tim, vor allen Dingen, du warst lange nicht hier.
Herzlich willkommen Jakob.
Ihr kennt Tim aus den letzten anderthalb Jahren vor allen Dingen aus dem Chaos Radio Express. Der quasi das zweite Schiff, das Mutterschiff zum Chaos Radio. Da können wir nachher noch mal kurz drauf eingehen oder lang drauf eingehen, wie auch immer. Aber heute geht es um Twitter.
Ja, wir können ja vielleicht das erst mal beantworten, dann müssen wir danach nicht noch mal drauf eingehen. Also Chaos Radio Express ist, also das hier gibt es ja auf Fritz und live und UKW. Und Chaos Radio Express gibt es nur im Internet als Podcast. Und naja, es ist manchmal sehr lang, aber da geht es halt immer so ganz spezifisch um ein Thema. Und da wird dann ganz lange in Ruhe geredet. Also es ist ein Interview Podcast, das heißt, es ist meistens ich und eine oder zwei, aber manchmal auch drei andere Personen. Und dann wird halt ein Thema so lange durchgekaut, bis es nichts mehr hergibt.
Und es können alle möglichen Themen sein, oder alle tot umfallen. Es können alle möglichen Themen sein. Du hattest in der letzten Zeit einen Chaos Radio Express zum Thema Kaffee. Das fand ich ganz spannend. Da ging es nur um Kaffee.
Ah, das ist denn gehört. Ah ja, genau. Da ging es nur um Kaffee. Also es geht nicht nur um Technik, sondern es geht generell Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft und dann eben auch mal um Kaffee. So alles von wo das herkommt in Ägypten, Äthiopien und dann, was weiß ich, wie man eigentlich einen guten Kaffee zubereitet. Kaffeebohnen, schweißende Affen und andere Sachen. Da ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu holen. Und da würde ich mich natürlich freuen, wenn die Leute, die es noch nicht kennen, da auch mal reinhören.
Chaosradio.ccc.de ist die Webseite. Da gibt es auch den Link zum Chaosradio Express. Da gibt es den Podcast der letzten Chaosradios und auch der letzten CAEs. Falls ihr da jetzt bemüht, sich da mal reinzuhören, macht das bitte gerne. Aber heute ist das Thema der Sendung Twitter und ihr könnt gerne natürlich anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110 oder euch im Chat auch an der Sendung beteiligen. Twitter.
Genau, genau. Das ist das Thema nicht Twitter, sondern das Thema ist Twitter Demokratie. Das ist so ein Name, den ich mir ad hoc habe einfallen lassen, um einfach auszudrücken, worüber wir reden wollen. Nämlich über den Einfluss moderner Kommunikationsmedien, also internetbasierter Kommunikationsmedien, auf unseren gesellschaftlichen Apparat. Also welchen Einfluss das für die Gesellschaft hat. Und zwar auch nicht nur für uns. Natürlich hat das ganze so einen globalen Aspekt. Wie man ja gerade schön sehen kann, im Iran alle traditionellen Medien verstummen, weil sie einfach nicht mehr senden können, nicht mehr senden dürfen. Und alle stürzen sich jetzt auf das Internet. Sie stürzen sich auf YouTube, weil dort viele Filme erscheinen. Nicht nur dort, aber vor allem dort. Sie stürzen sich auf Flickr, weil da große Fotoalben entstehen, wo viel dokumentiert wird. Sie stürzen sich eigentlich auf alles Mögliche, was bisher etabliert war. Sie stürzen sich aber vor allem auf Twitter, weil Twitter wie der neue Heißkleber im Internet fungiert und die ganzen Sachen zusammenzieht und eine Kommunikationskultur ermöglicht und eröffnet hat, die bis vor kurzem so noch nicht existiert hat.
Ich stelle sich die Frage, warum gibt es das erst jetzt, wenn das so brillant und super ist? Warum ist das nicht schon vor 50 Jahren erfunden worden?
Na, vor 50 Jahren gab es halt einfach die Grundlagen dafür noch nicht. Vor fünf Jahren gab es die Grundlagen dafür auch noch nicht. Sicherlich hätte Twitter jetzt auch, was weiß ich, ein Jahr früher oder so kommen. Aber die Dinge werden natürlich auch immer dann groß, wenn die Zeit dafür reif ist. Und das war es halt hier aus vielen Gründen. Manche Dienste, die heute uns selbstverständlich erachten, hätte man wahrscheinlich auch vor einigen Jahren den Leuten so noch überhaupt nicht vermitteln können, weil einfach auch eine gewisse Erfahrung mit dem Umgang und dem Netz gefehlt hat. Und ich habe eben auch schon heißkleber gesagt, es fasst halt alles zusammen. Also Twitter wäre jetzt ohne die anderen auch irgendwie nüscht. Das wäre dann halt nur so Texte und so her. Aber es werden halt links gepostet ins Web. Es werden links gepostet eben auch auf diese ganzen anderen Dienste, die ich gerade schon erläutert habe.
Ich habe dich auch gerade getwittert.
Du hast mich gerade getwittert? Genau.
Ed Huckel hat noch schnell ein Foto gemacht.
Genau. H-U-K-L. Und jetzt hast du mich aber auch erfolgreich aus dem Konzept gebracht. Also es fasst das halt alles zusammen. Aber darüber hinaus ist es einfach so eine neue Art von globalem Chatraum, wo Leute auf gleicher Augenhöhe miteinander diskutieren können und das jetzt auch tun. Und das ist halt lange Zeit auch ausreichend belächelt worden. Du kennst das sicherlich, so die Standardargumente. Ach, schon wieder was Neues und ich habe keine Zeit dafür. Ganz klar, da muss jeder wissen, was man macht. Aber ist das nicht auch alles belanglos? Und darüber wollen wir halt reden. Damit wollen wir auch mit euch drüber reden, was ihr schon für Erfahrungen gesammelt habt. Vor allem würde uns natürlich Erfahrungen interessieren, die jetzt gerade im Kontext der Debatten, die zuletzt so auf Twitter vor allem ausgefochten wurden. Das ist einerseits natürlich die Iran-Wahl. Wer das beobachtet hat, da würden wir uns natürlich über Feedback freuen. Aber auch, wir müssen gar nicht so weit zurückgucken. Hier in Deutschland hat es genauso gebrannt, die ganze Debatte um die Einführung von Internetzensuren in Form von sogenannten Sperren, um angeblich halt die sogenannte Kinderpornografie zu verhindern. Das war ja ein Riesenaufstand und auch das wäre in seiner ganzen Mobilisierung so ohne Twitter nicht vorstellbar gewesen.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, wie Twitter und all diese Sachen funktionieren. Wir haben ja über diese Zensurdebatte auch an dieser Stelle im letzten halben Jahr, glaube ich, zwei, alleine zwei Sendungen gemacht. Und das ist, glaube ich, jetzt auch überall angekommen, dass allein durch die Diskussion auf der Ebene, die nicht Zeitungen, Stammtisch, am Frühstück, bei der Arbeit oder so funktionieren, dass es eine viel größere Sensibilität gibt, dass Leute erst mal überhaupt darauf aufmerksam gemacht werden, dass das Thema ein bisschen größer ist, als du es in den drei Schlagzeilen in der Bahnhofszeitung liest.
Ja. Hast du dir jetzt eigentlich schon einen Twitter-Account gemacht?
Vor drei Minuten, klar.
Echt? Wie heißt der? Du musst ja einen Namen gewählt haben. Ostbrot. Ostbrot. Du bist Ostbrot? twitter.com/ostbrot. Du startest halt ohne Leute. Wir wollen ja auch mal ein bisschen kurz erklären, vielleicht für die Leute, die jetzt so mit diesem Twitter-Phänomen noch nicht so zusammengeprallt sind oder sich bisher erfolgreich gewehrt haben dagegen. Also ich habe jetzt hier deinen Account vor der Nase. Du hast jetzt schon mal einen Tweet abgesetzt, eine Kurznachricht. Da gibt es ja diese schöne Analogie zur SMS, weil das halt auch so gekürzt ist. Noch ein bisschen kürzer als eine SMS, maximal 140 Zeichen eben. Und was halt ein Merkmal ist von Twitter und was auch ein Grund dafür ist, dass das so erfolgreich ist, das ist halt nicht so, wie man das aus den ganzen anderen Netzen kennt mit diesen Freunden, wo man ja immer gleich so eine bidirektionale Beziehung aufmacht, die man vielleicht gar nicht so will, sondern es ist eben so ein asynchrones Kommunikationssystem. Das heißt, wer einen liest und wen man liest, das hat so erst mal nichts miteinander zu tun, sondern man wählt selber, wen man liest und wenn man halt niemanden wählt, den man folgt, wie man das so schön sagt, dann sieht man halt nichts. So, dann kann man halt dieses Twitter-Universum hineinschreiben und da können dann Leute vielleicht auch lesen, was ich schreibe, aber wenn man halt selber niemanden folgt, dann nimmt das genau keine Zeit von mir, außer die, die ich damit verbringe, selber was zu schreiben.
Und auch das ist sicher ein Aspekt des Twitter-Themas, dass es genug Twitterer gibt, die die digitale Müllhalle jeden Tag mit Informationen füllen, wie ich gehe jetzt zur Straßenbahn und die ist zwei Minuten zu spät.
Aber es ist nicht so irrelevant, wie das immer so dargestellt wird. Also ich finde diese Diskussion ganz schwierig, weil dieses, ich schreibe darüber, was ich tu und was ich lasse und was ich esse und so. Klar, da kann man schnell sagen, das ist irrelevant. Aber wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie so der normale Schwatz zwischen Leuten einfach abläuft, das basiert alles immer auf den normalen Banalitäten. Und so uninteressant ist das auch gar nicht, weil eigentlich interessiert ist, die Leute brennt. Der normale Klatschweiberklatsch, der dreht sich genau um diese Sachen. Und da steckt ja auch eine ganze Menge drin. Da steckt eine ganze Menge drin, insofern, als dass damit ja auch soziale Regeln aufgestellt werden, soziale Regeln durchgesetzt werden. Die Leute tun Dinge nicht, weil sie sich darüber Gedanken machen, was die anderen darüber sagen. Und die Leute reden wieder, das ist eigentlich die stärkste Klammer, die so eine Gesellschaft hat. Deswegen kann man das gar nicht so abtun. Und jetzt ein Medium zu haben im Netz, was eben diesen Klatschweiberkram, also nicht nur Weiber, also Klatsch halt einfach, abbildet, das ist einfach spannend. So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob du schon gefolgt wirst.
Während du guckst, kann ich eine Geschichte, eine Twitter-Geschichte erzählen, die mir in der letzten Zeit begegnet ist, die weder was mit Iran noch mit der Zensur-Debatte zu tun hat, sondern wir haben ja bei Fritzi auch viel mit Künstlern zu tun, die zum Interview kommen und die hier auf dem Weg zu uns sind. Du musst vorher, wär es schon schön zu erfahren, wie ist er eigentlich drauf? Wir haben nur fünf Minuten Zeit, ist der gerade knorrig, ist er krank oder so? Ja, ja, und da gab's zwei Leute, ich hab den Namen, glaub ich, nicht mehr, es war Lilly Allen, und Miss Lee war die andere aus Schweden, die dann die eine tippt, ja, ich bin am Flughafen, bin zu spät, ich werde mich verspäten, ich bin auch krank, hab gestern Abend, war der Abend ein bisschen lang, war noch unterwegs, und du weißt in dem Moment schon, ah, eine gute Frau ist knurrig. Also, kaufst du mal einen Kaffee, ist die Situation gleich ganz anders. Oder, weiß was ich, dass sie dann sagen, war gerade bei Fritz, bin auf dem Weg jetzt nach Berlin zurück, spielte heute Abend ein Konzert, denkst du, ah cool, weiß die halbe Welt, dass sie ein Interview gemacht hat, ohne dass die Leute vielleicht in dem Moment fritz hören. Von daher ist das auch schon wieder ganz nett.
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall auch Leute, die, wie du schon sagtest, die halt twittern, dass ihre Straßenbahn zu spät ist oder eben der ICE-Verspätung hat. Und für die einen ist das halt total belanglos. Sowas interessiert mich das. Aber für den anderen, der vielleicht auch den gleichen ICE nehmen wollte und das zufällig halt auch mit aufschnappt, ist das dann schon wieder eine wertvolle Information.
Ich habe auch schon jemand getroffen im gleichen Zug, weil wir sozusagen von einer Person beide, also wir kannten uns noch nicht so richtig, waren schon so in einer ähnlichen Szene unterwegs. Aber uns beide lasen halt dieselbe Person, die dann so uns beide fragte, seid ihr denn etwa im gleichen Zug? Und dann haben wir uns da sozusagen auch gefunden.
Huckel hat vorhin, da wir gerade bei Beispiel sind, Huckel hat vorhin die Geschichte erzählt aus dem Club von einem Kollegen, der irgendwie einen Keyboard zu viel hatte und das loswerden wollte.
Genau, der hat irgendwie, also wir hatten gerade im Club das Thema, Twitter ist ja blöd oder auch nicht, und dann schwenkte das Thema ab, dass er seine alte Tastatur dem Computerhändler übergeben hat, weil der das einem Künstler für ein Kunstprojekt mit alten Tastaturen geben wollte. So, der hat sich aber natürlich nicht bei ihm gemeldet, er wusste nichts mehr darüber und er dachte sich, schreibe ich da mal ins Twitter, ob jemand was von diesem Kunstprojekt weiß, und es hat halt keine Minute gedauert. Da hat er zwei Antworten gehabt. Ja, hier, guck mal da, Link hier, Link da. Und dann hat er dieses Kunstprojekt mit seiner Tastatur sozusagen gefunden. Und das war halt auch sehr beeindruckend, dass das innerhalb von einer Minute sofort kam. Und hat natürlich auch die Zweifler erstmal wieder verstummen lassen.
Also Lebenshilfe ganz schnell. Wir hatten vorhin gesagt, Huckel, du kannst einfach jedes Tech-Word eingeben, such wonach du willst. Ich such nach Gemüsebeet und findest sofort einen Eintrag, wo jemand sagt, ja, bei Ameisen im Gemüsebeet mach ich ja immer Backpulver drauf. Wobei es nicht das Markenbackpulver sein muss, sondern es geht auch das Einfache. Und so hast du auch die kleinen Sachen im Haushalt gelöst. Innerhalb von zehn Minuten für eine Geschichte begeistert, Tim.
Ja, das ist halt das Ding. Man ist auf einmal so, man ist einfach vernetzt im besten Sinne des Wortes.
Ihr könnt uns, oder ihr könnt nicht, ihr sollt uns auch anrufen und mit uns über Twitter reden. Wie nutzt ihr Twitter? Wofür nutzt ihr Twitter? Und habt ihr in den letzten Wochen und Monaten von den Sachen, die auf der Welt passieren, von Iran über Zensurdebatte, Twitter auch als Medium benutzt? 0331 70 97 1 1 1 0, wir würden uns über eure Anrufe sehr freuen. Wir haben auch schon den ersten am Telefon, wollen wir gleich mal reingucken? Am Telefon ist Florian, hallo Florian. Florian, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Hessen.
Aus Hessen?
Bei Limburg an der Lahn.
Da du keine junge Frau bist, ist es nicht unvermessen, dich zu fragen, wie alt du bist? 18? Twitterst du?
Offensichtlich.
Ja, ich hatte vorhin bei dem Anmelden für den Talk einen falschen Twitter-Nickname genannt. Jetzt über Twitter, wo wir jetzt reden.
Tja, ich glaub du bist ein bisschen an der falschen Adresse, kann das sein?
Nö, warum?
Na wo bist du denn jetzt?
Ich wollte nur sagen, dass ich halt bei twitter.com einige Twitter-Dateien habe und auch gerne Twitter.
Ja, was twitterst du denn? Also was sind die Nachrichten, die du der Welt mitteilst?
Was ich so gerade mache, beispielsweise habe ich vor paar Tagen getwittert, dass ich Radio mache. Das ist selbst Webradio oder jetzt vor nicht mal zehn Sekunden habe ich halt reingeschrieben, dass ich jetzt bei euch im Fritz Radio talke.
Dann sag uns doch schnell dein Twitter-Account, dann gucken wir uns das gleich mal an. Flo176, alles klar. Dann gucken wir uns das gleich mal an Flo, viel Spaß noch in der Sendung und wir gucken weiter, wenn noch am Telefon ist.
Das war jetzt nicht so ganz das Feedback, worauf wir gewartet haben, aber man muss sich ja auch steigern können.
Da, bin im Radio bei Fritz in Berlin. Muss hier zum Mikrofon kommen, bin im Radio bei Fritz in Berlin, hat er geschrieben.
Schönen Selbstreferenz hier.
Aber leider funktioniert gerade das mit dem Following scheinbar nicht so.
Interessanterweise scheinen wir jetzt gerade da wieder in so eine Bugphase zu stoßen. Also Twitter hatte ja auch eine interessante technische Geschichte. Der Dienst wurde mal gestartet und die Twitter-Gründer selbst waren eigentlich von dem Erfolg und vor allem auch davon, wie es genutzt wird, total überrascht.
Warum haben die das eigentlich gestartet? Kennst du die Geschichte?
Ja, das ist halt grob. Die haben halt mal wieder dran. Das waren ja die Jungs, die blogger.com dann an Google verkauft haben und da wahrscheinlich auch die ein oder andere Markt gemacht haben. Dann saßen sie langweilig rum. Na ja gut, keine Ahnung, worum es denn ging. Auf jeden Fall wollten sie jetzt nicht einfach nur am Strand liegen, sondern haben sich gedacht, jetzt machen wir mal was anderes und kamen halt so einfach auf die Idee, na ja, man könnte ja so einen Dienst machen, der dann auch sich leicht mit SMS koppeln lässt, deswegen diese Längenbeschränkungen, in denen die Leute halt einfach ihren Status sozusagen, wie es gerade um mich bestellt ist. Diese Standardfrage bei Twitter lautet ja auch, what are you doing?
Also ich hätte da noch ein bisschen Background-Informationen, die ein bisschen detailreicher sind, auch kurz. Also die hatten eine eigene Firma gegründet danach, odeo.com, die gibt es auch immer noch.
Stimmt, genau, das haben die vorher noch gemacht.
Medienkram gemacht und waren aber nicht so erfolgreich und von anderen wurden in das Wasser abgegraben und da haben sie halt sozusagen schon mal ein paar Teams gegründet und ein bisschen Brainstorming gemacht, was man noch so machen könnte und in einem Team war halt einer dabei, der vorher Blogger verkauft hat und der hatte eben diese Idee, ja wir machen jetzt für unsere Freunde eben so einen Dienst, wo man dann immer sehen kann, was die anderen Freunde gerade so machen. Also wenn einer bei einer Party ist, sehe ich das auf meinem Telefon per SMS eben und kann dann da auch mit hingehen. Und dann haben die halt sozusagen als erstes mal so einen kleinen Prototypen gemacht, wirklich nur für die Freunde und die Firmenkollegen und so weiter und das war eben nur per SMS, weil damals gab es halt noch nicht so Internet auf dem Telefon und um eben diese Textnachrichten hin und her zu schicken, hatten sie das halt dann übers Telefon gemacht. Genau. Und ja, am Anfang war halt auch noch gar nicht klar, dass das irgendwie abgeht und das wuchs halt so periodisch immer mehr an.
Ja, also womit sie vor allem nicht gerechnet haben, ist, dass die Leute das dann eben eher nutzen wie ein Chat. Die dachten so, na ja, man macht jetzt so einmal so das, hm, und sagt das und dann können das Leute so nachschlagen. Aber dass dann so eine Antwortkultur daraus entstand, das war am Anfang nicht vorgesehen. Das heißt, all diese Sachen, die jetzt in Twitter auch wirklich eingebaut sind, wie dieses, ich antworte jemandem, in dem ich add sein Name und bla bla bla schreibe, das war am Anfang eine Konvention, die sich die Leute selber ausgedacht haben und die dann eben Zug um Zug auch in die technische Basis von Twitter eingebaut wurde. Und auch einige weitere Dinge, die später noch so mit erfolgen. Heute nennt man das halt Mansions. Und es ist ja so, ich sehe halt, wenn ich jetzt nichts anderes einstelle, sehe ich halt das, was die Leute schreiben, denen ich folge. Ich sehe aber auch das, was Leute direkt an mich richten, selbst wenn ich ihnen nicht folge. Und dadurch können halt auch Leute auf einen zukommen, die man so noch gar nicht auf dem Radar hat. Aber die einen vielleicht selbst auf dem Radar haben und die eben auf irgendetwas antworten, was man schreibt. Und so gewinnt man dann sozusagen neue Kontakte und kommt halt ins Gespräch. Twitter war dann in kurzer Zeit so erfolgreich, dass ihr Software-Modell so nicht ausgereicht hat. Also so wie sie sich das dachten, wie die Leute das benutzten, ist es halt nicht passiert. Und so wie sie es dann benutzt haben, hat es ihre Maschine komplett überlastet. Aber die haben sich dann ordentlich Kohle rangeholt und sind jetzt seit gutem Jahr dabei, alles neu zu schreiben und haben da auch schon Erfolge erzielt.
Schreibt gerade auch einer im Chat hier irgendwie. Immer wenn Twitter nicht geht, ist grundsätzlich Ruby-on-Rails-Schuld beschwerden gehen an Hucke, der Herr Ruby-Advokat ist.
Auf unseren Chats sollten wir nochmal hinweisen. Wir haben im irc.freenote.net den Kanal Chaosradio, da könnt ihr auch dazu stoßen, wenn ihr wollt.
Oder uns anrufen und uns erzählen, wozu ihr Twitter nutzt. Wir klingeln mal rüber zu Richard. Hallo Richard, guten Abend. Hallo. Wofür nutzt du Twitter? Was war dein letzter Tweet?
Ich nutze Twitter selber nicht, aber ich bin jetzt gerade auf dem Weg nach Hause und hatte kurz im Radio herumgespielt und da war Deutschlandfunk gerade im Anschlag. Und da hatten die gerade das Thema von wegen, dass ja Journalisten auch Twitter nutzen, um ihre Stories zu überprüfen. Das ging direkt um eine kleine Frau im Iran und da hat die ostamerikanische Journalistin halt in Twitter geschrieben, ob jemand dieses Mädchen kennt und hat es zwei Minuten später schon in Link zu jemandem, der diese Mädchen kennt. Es ist schon sehr erstaunlich, dass das auch so funktioniert.
Ja, das ist in der Tat erstaunlich und gerade jetzt im Iran spielt natürlich Twitter eine besondere Rolle, weil das Land nach innen eigentlich medial abgeschottet ist, das heißt die klassischen Medien, Fernsehen, Radio und so weiter ist halt alles kontrolliert von einer Macht, die einfach bestimmte Informationen so eben nicht bringen möchte und es ist aber so, Iran ist eine recht fortschrittliche Gesellschaft, zumindest in den Städten, die das Netz extensiv nutzen, das ist jetzt auch sozusagen nichts Neues, das ist schon seit einiger Zeit so, Blogs waren schon immer sehr groß im Iran und jetzt sind halt Blogs und aber eben vor allem Twitter, weil das eben auch schwerer abzuschalten ist, nämlich fast gar nicht, wie sich ja zeigt, als jetzt irgendwelche Blogs, die sind jetzt eigentlich der Träger Das ist ein Erzähler der Informationen und der Staat hat so seine Schwierigkeiten damit, das unter Kontrolle zu bringen. Na ja, wie wir ja hier sehen, gerade die Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat ja jetzt auch die Einführung der Internetzensur beschlossen. Es gibt natürlich schon so Mittel und Wege, bloß Twitter ist jetzt, ganz spezifisch Twitter, ist nicht so ohne weiteres in den Griff zu kriegen, weil es ebenso funktioniert, wie es funktioniert.
Aber ist es denn, also bei einem Blog, ist ja über den Host auch rauszukriegen, wer dieses Blog führt. Also sollten in Blogs Sachen auftauchen, die gegen die Grundgesetz, gegen das Grundgesetz, gegen die Menschenwürde, was auch immer verstoßen, lässt es sich ja rauskriegen, wer das gerade in die Welt boostet. Geht das bei Twitter auch? Oder ist Twitter in dem Sinne dann auch Kontroll, entzieht sich der Kontrolle?
Na ja, also es ist weitestgehend komplett ungefiltert, aber es gibt schon von den Twitter-Betreibern schon auch die Bestrebungen, Spammer zum Beispiel zu blocken und die Accounts zu löschen. Es ist also natürlich prinzipiell möglich, dass die unliebsame User immer mal rauskicken. Die können sich natürlich gleich wieder einen neuen Account machen und so weiter, aber zumindest auf der Inhaltsebene wird er jetzt nicht wirklich gefiltert oder geblockt.
Ja, also der Kampf gegen Spam ist auch bei Twitter ein Thema. Hat sich allerdings bisher noch nicht als so ein großes Problem gezeigt. Das ist nicht gesagt, dass das so bleiben wird, weil das Interesse an Twitter natürlich weiter steigt, aber eben so wie es eben auch funktioniert, gerade mit diesem asymmetrischen Folgen, ist es so, dass Spammer jetzt erstmal nicht so ein offenes Scheunentor vorfinden wie bei E-Mail. Und andererseits in dem Moment, wo sie unangenehm auffallen, auch schnell auffallen.
Weil die Menge der Leute, die draufguckt, die die Tweets mitliest, noch größer ist.
Ja, und es gibt dann auch so, ich glaube der heißt einfach Ad Spam, bei Twitter so ein Account, dem kann man dann auch Tipps geben und so, wenn man der Meinung ist, hier läuft was falsch. Und alles das, was mir bisher so aufgefallen ist, ist dann auch relativ schnell wieder verschwunden. Man kann halt auch blocken und da quasi auch schon indirekt so einen Hinweis geben. Ja, aber so eine Zensur findet, soweit wir das beurteilen können, derzeit bei Twitter nicht statt. Und ich hoffe natürlich auch, dass das so bleibt.
Du hast gerade die Netzsperren angesprochen, also die Internetzensur, andersrum gesagt. Da haben wir gleich zwei Anrufer, die dazu was sagen wollen. Wollen wir gleich mal weiter switchen? Richard, ist es okay, wenn wir gleich uns von dir verabschieden? Alles klar, komm gut nach Hause, ne? Am Telefon ist Lars. Hallo, Lars. Hallo, grüß dich. Und warte mal, Stefan ist auch am Telefon. Der hat was zum selben Thema zu sagen. Die holen wir gleich mit rein. Hallo, Stefan. Tachchen, der Fernishalber fängt Lars an, der ist weiter vorne im Alphabet.
Also ich bin der Puppe, ich twitte auch und ich wollte zwei Geschichten sagen zu Twitter. Das erste war, als hier die Bombedrohung war im Hauptbahnhof. Da war es so, dass wir im Hauptbahnhof nicht rausgelassen wurden mit der Bahn und man wusste, hat halt keine Information bekommen von der Bahn.
Weil der Zugchef nur sagt, das wird sich verzögern.
Ja, man wusste halt einfach, man war in einem indefiniten Loch. Ja, und da konnte man über Twitter gucken, was ist in meinem Umkreis, was gibt es da für Nachrichten irgendwie mit Bombe, weil irgendjemand hatte irgendein Gerücht gehört. Und so wusste man dann innerhalb von einer Viertelstunde über Twitter, dass eine Bombendrohung am Hauptbahnhof gewesen war. Während, ja, in allen anderen Medien, weil ich hatte dann direkt mal zu Hause im Internet geschaut, irgendwie was hier Berliner Zeitung und Co. sagen. Ja, die wussten alle noch gar nichts.
Ja, das ist lustig, dass du das gerade ansprichst. Da bin ich nämlich gerade in dem Moment, als der Bahnhof gesperrt wurde, bin ich gerade mit dem ICE eingefahren in den Hauptbahnhof und wollte da eigentlich auch aussteigen. Und dann kam so die Durchsage mit, wir halten jetzt hier mal nicht, wir fahren weiter.
Ja, lustigerweise hab ich das dann wiederum bei dir gelesen.
Also an der recursiven Kleide.
Ja, genau. Als ich beim Ostbahnhof war, da wusste ich dann schon, worum es geht.
Was ich auf jeden Fall noch sagen wollte zu Twitter ist, dass alle Netzaktivisten das so extrem irgendwie mobilisiert. Also es gibt einem auch so ein bisschen Zuversicht, dass man nicht alleine ist. Und wenn ich dann zum Beispiel so eine Sache lese, wie von Max den Ausspruch, ihr werdet euch noch wünschen, wir seien unpolitisch, dann geht das halt rum und es wird zitiert wiederum von anderen Leuten. Und dann sieht man, ey genau, da sieht man, dass da halt dann auch eine Macht ist, die wie heißt es, durch die entsprechenden Multiplikatoren noch weitergereicht werden kann.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt, du hast das Gefühl, nicht alleine zu sein oder alleine zu sein. Es gibt ja auch eine Region, die weniger dicht besiedelt sind, wo Leute das Gefühl haben, sie sitzen allein auf ihrer Insel und alle anderen rundherum wissen überhaupt nicht, was sie da treiben. Du merkst eben, du hast gleichgesinnte Arztgenossen, nenn es wie du willst. Es gibt einem natürlich auch Zuversicht und auch Motivation weiterzumachen.
Ja, wenn man dann so am Donnerstag zum ersten Mal auf diese Demo zum Beispiel da gegen dieses Gesetz dann da aufläuft und man sieht so dann die üblichen Verdächtigen, die man vorher nur so aus der Twitter-Sphäre oder so nennt oder die Twitterier, wie es manchen nennen, kann ich mich da schon sowohl amüsieren, aber irgendwie ist das dann wirklich wie so ein gemeinsamer Kampf. Und wenn man dann noch sieht, diese Macht, die dann teilweise aus diesen Hashtags entstehen, das war also ganz spannend als jetzt dieser Bundesparteitag war von der SPD und man bekam so mit auf Twitter, wie viele Politik Interessierte das halt auch verfolgt haben. Und als dann, wie heißt es, dieser Antrag dort abgelehnt wurde, weil er medial nicht erwünscht war, sah man direkt, wie daraus sich dann auch wieder so eine neue Welle eigentlich für uns entwickelt hat. Und ja, ich finde es einfach sehr spannend, was sozusagen Twitter uns an Möglichkeiten gibt.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Phänomen, was mir wirklich sehr gefällt, dass man eben dann so in kürzester Zeit so einen Druckpunkt wirklich konzentriert erzeugen kann. Und hier bei der Iran-Geschichte war es ja auch so, dass irgendwie am Anfang, als das losging, irgendwie dann alle getwittert haben, warum ist das nicht auf CNN? Und haben dann das Hashtag CNN-Fail gemacht. Und dann gab es da in kürzester Zeit irgendwie 100.000 Tweets mit CNN-Fail. Und dann irgendwie ein paar Stunden später oder am nächsten Tag hat dann CNN-Bericht gebracht, so darüber und irgendwie. Man hat dann tatsächlich so dieses Gefühl, man übt jetzt so konzentriert gesammelt Druck auf irgendeinen Punkt aus.
Beziehungsweise das, was Lars sagte mit dem Hauptbahnhof. Du stehst da und keiner weiß, was eigentlich los ist. Du bist gar nicht mehr darauf angewiesen, dass irgendein Medium darüber berichtet, was in deiner Welt stattfindet, weil du entweder die Information selber generierst oder weißt, von wem du sie dir holst.
Wobei natürlich spannend da war, dass Twitter extra das Wartungsfenster für den Iran dann verschoben hat, weil sozusagen gerade dort so eine Welle losgetreten wurde, dass man irgendwie nicht wollte, die jetzt irgendwie abebben zu lassen, weil man jetzt temporär Twitter mal offline nimmt.
Ja, weil die User da auch wieder ordentlich Druck gemacht haben.
Ja, richtig.
Lars, danke dir für den Anruf. Wir haben noch Stefan und machen gleich noch Nachrichten.
Klar, ich wünsche euch noch eine gute Sendung.
Alles klar.
Dazu noch mal zwei Sachen, die man vielleicht kurz erwähnen sollte. Dieses Zitieren ist ja auch wieder so eine eigene Kultur. Wer mal bei Twitter reingeschaut hat und sich ein paar Nachrichten hat, vorbeifliegen sehen wird, gesehen haben, vieles fängt halt so an mit RT. RT steht für Retweet sozusagen, das Twitter-Zitat. Und in der Regel ist es halt so eins zu eins eben der Beitrag von jemand anderem. Das heißt, man sagt halt RT, dann der Name, der das eigentlich geschrieben hat, plus das, was er gesagt hat. Manchmal muss man da so ein bisschen verkürzend eingreifen, weil man natürlich dann durch die Verlängerung an das Maximum der Nachricht stößt. Aber das funktioniert an sich ganz gut. Und das trägt dann eben eine wichtige Nachricht oder das, was eben Leute als wichtig erachten, eben sehr schnell dann eben über die Follower, der Follower, der Follower zu einem Schneeballsystem, was ganz automatisch funktioniert. Und deswegen sind eben auch so wichtige und aktuelle Sachen auch binnen Minuten dann in der Aufmerksamkeit von Leuten. Und diese Hashtags, die er angesprochen hat, das ist ja auch so eine Konvention. Das muss man nicht unbedingt so machen, aber es bietet sich an, weil es so schön explizit ist. Sprich, wenn man sich auf ein bestimmtes Ereignis oder einen sonstigen Kontext bezieht, dann nimmt man eben so einen griffigen Begriff, den die anderen eben wohl auch nehmen. Oder man weiß eben auch schon welchen. Gerade bei Konferenzen einigt man sich im Vorfeld sogar auch schon an solchen. Fügt das einfach mit in die Nachricht ein. Das ist dieses Lattenzaunzeichen. Und dann eben wie dieses CNN-Fail. Und dann taucht das nämlich bei Twitter in diesen Trends auf. Die aktuellen Trendwörter. Und dann steigt das eben in 0, 0 nach oben. Ein Flugzeugabsturz und so eine Sachen. Das ist dann eben in 0, 0 am Start. So, Stefan?
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ja, also wie bin ich zu Twitter gekommen?
Also ich hab bis vor ein paar Wochen selber noch gedacht, dass Twitter wirklich bloß auch so ein Medium ist, wo jeder halt schreibt, ich trinke jetzt gerade eine Tasse Kaffee oder mach sonst irgendwas völlig alltägliches.
Und ich hab vor ein paar Wochen noch gesagt, bei Twitter werde ich mich nie anmelden.
Weil ich dann doch einfach mal neugierig war und es einfach mal ausprobieren wollte, um da auch ein bisschen mitreden zu können. Ich bin ja auch schon ein bisschen älter mit 35.
Und ja, hab dann aber auch sehr schnell gemerkt, dass da grad hier unglaublich was abgeht, was vor allen Dingen so die Sache mit dem Internet-Zensurgesetz anbelangt. Und bin durch Twitter eigentlich erst mal darauf aufmerksam gemacht worden, was da eigentlich überhaupt beschlossen ist. Also in verschiedenen Blogs und so weiter, die dann hier gepostet worden sind, hab ich mich dann schlau gemacht. Und ja, im Moment ist es so, dass ich im Moment erst bei Twitter gucke, was gibt's da Neues bei diesem Thema, und dann erst die sogenannten Mainstream-Medien absurfe und mich bei der Tagesschau oder sonst was informiere, weil ich einfach das Gefühl habe, dass bei Twitter hier erstens alles aktueller ist und dann in der Masse der Information auch ein bisschen tiefgründiger.
Weil du auf viel mehr Leute zugreifst.
Genau so ist es.
Und man kann nachfragen, wenn man eine Frage hat. Das geht bei der Tagesschau auch schlecht.
Du kannst ja anrufen.
Genau so ist es.
Und was ich auch eine sehr vorderhafte Funktion des Ganzen finde, ist, dass man ja auch die Politiker und die Leute, die sowas entscheiden, direkt anschreiben kann. Und die dann im Gegensatz zu E-Mail-Verkehr oder sowas, einem dann meistens auch relativ schnell antworten.
Echt, hattest du schon Politiker, die dir antworten? Ich hab das bisher noch nicht geschafft.
Und ja, also das ist natürlich jetzt nicht die allererste Reihe. Aber auch der Herr Taus, der da jetzt gerade aus der SPD ausgetreten ist, der hat auch auf meine Anfrage hin reagiert.
Und ja, was ich eben halt auch merke, ist, dass man hier wirklich eine Gemeinschaft zum Gleichgesinnten finden kann.
Und das relativ schnell.
So viel Lob in den ersten knapp 30 Minuten vom Chaosradio. Wir haben nachher noch mehr Zeit für euch.
Ich will natürlich auch noch einen kurzen Kritikpunkt an Twitter anbelangen. Also es gibt ja gerade dieses Zensur-Solidit.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr davon schon was gehört habt.
250.000 Klicks glaube ich gerade auf YouTube. Und das wird hier natürlich auch alle 10 Sekunden gepostet.
Irgendwie zumindest war das gestern noch so. Heute ist es ein bisschen ruhiger.
Das ist dann natürlich der andere Fall. Also dass dann Sachen immer wieder gebracht werden, die eigentlich schon längst seit zwei, drei Tagen durch sind.
Das ist der Nachteil bei Twitter eigentlich.
Nichts ist älter als die Information von vor fünf Minuten. Danke dir, Stefan. Ich muss jetzt ein bisschen Druck machen, weil jetzt kriegen wir eins auf den Deckel. Sechs Minuten nach halb elf.
Früher haben sich die Anwohner rund um den Flughafen Tempelhof immer über den Lärm beschwert. Tja, und das haben sie jetzt davon. Prinz präsentiert das Berlin-Festival. Laute, neue, aber vor allem lauter neue Musik live auf dem Flughafen Tempelhof. Mit Bonaparte. Jose Gonzalez, Dendemann und The Rhythmiers. Das Berlin-Festival.
Open Airport.
Am 7. und 8. August auf dem Flughafen Tempelhof mitten in Berlin. Karten gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt.
Mehr Infos fritz.de.
Das Berlin-Festival. Neue Musik, Live und Open Airport. Und das hört man.
Es ist ein bisschen nach kurz nach halb elf.
Nachrichten.
Mit mal gebargt.
Bei einem Anschlag in der irakischen Hauptstadt Bagdad sind am Abend mindestens 60 Menschen getötet worden. Nach Angaben der Behörden explodierte die Bombe auf einem beliebten Markt. Über 150 weitere Menschen wurden verletzt. Erst am Montag waren in Bagdad mehrere Menschen getötet worden, als ein Sprengsatz neben einem Bus mit Oberschülern explodierte. Das Überleben des Insolventen Versandhausers Quelle ist vorerst gesichert. Der Bürgschaftsausschuss von Bund und Ländern einigte sich darauf, Quelle einen Kredit zur Verfügung zu stellen. Der Bund und die Länder Bayern und Sachsen teilen sich das Darlehen von 50 Millionen Euro. Zuvor hatte es der Bund abgelehnt, Quelle eine Bürgschaft zu geben, da das Ausfallrisiko zu groß sei. In Schweinfurt hat ein Mann seine Tochter getötet, weil er mit ihrer Art zu leben nicht einverstanden war. Der türkische Gastwirt hatte die 15-Jährige am Morgen mit mehreren Messerstichen getötet. Nach Angaben der Polizei hatte es zwischen Vater und Tochter vorher immer wieder Streit gegeben. Gegen den 45-Jährigen erging am Abend Haftbefehl wegen Mordes. Start! Die deutschen Handballer haben bei der EM 2010 in Österreich eine schwere Vorrundengruppe erwischt. Sie müssen gegen Vize-Weltmeister Polen, gegen Schweden und Slowenien antreten. Das ergab heute die Auslösung in Wien. Die EM findet im Januar statt. Die Fußballnationalmannschaft der USA steht überraschend im Finale des Confederations Cup in Südafrika. Der Außenseiter hat das Halbfinale gegen Europameister Spanien mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Der Finalgegner wird morgen zwischen Brasilien und Gastgeber Südafrika ermittelt. Das Finale findet dann am Sonntag statt. Heute Nacht im Süden noch einzelne Schauer und Gewitter, später wechselnd bewölkt und zunächst kaum Regen. Die Tiefstärte liegen bei 12 Grad. Der Tag beginnt dann mit Schauern und Gewittern, die von der Oder und Neiße herkommen. Es gibt viele Wolken und immer wieder Regen bei maximal 22 Grad. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Werder. Zwischen Rangsdorf und Genshagen gibt es Fahrbahnerneuerungen, deswegen sind da zwei Spuren gesperrt. A12 Berlin, Richtung Frankfurt Oder, zwischen Storke und Fürstenwalde West, gibt es Behinderungen durch einen defekten LKW. Fahrt da besonders vorsichtig. Und statt Verkehr Berlin, A113, der Zubringer Schönefeld, statt einwärts, zwischen Adlershof und Spätstraße, ist die Autobahn wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Sonst überall.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann wird's rund um Spremberg.
Am Mittwochabend mit dem Chaos Computer Club Puckl ist hier, Tim ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und ihr seid eingeladen mit uns über Twitter zu reden. Twittert ihr, wenn ja, seit wann, warum und wozu benutzt ihr es? Klingelt uns durch unter 0331 70 97 110. Nächster am Telefon ist Leon. Hallo Leon, grüß dich. Hallo, musstest ein bisschen warten, ich hoffe es ist jetzt nicht schlimm. Allklar, du twitters, seit wann? Wie alt bist du? 14. Wieso hast du angefangen zu twittern?
Ich wurde von einem Kanton darauf hingewiesen und habe mir meinen Account angelegt, Rainer Spaß erst mal. Und irgendwann merke ich immer wieder, wie sinnvoll der Service, also das begann auf der Republika 2008. Und dann konnte man sich einfach mit Leuten treffen, die gerade gesagt haben, ich stehe gerade hier. Und dann konnte man hingehen und direkt mit denen sprechen und jetzt Zensursula und Iron Election haben glaube ich noch mal gezeigt, wie stark das Medium auch bewegen kann. Und dass man irgendwie einen Link zu einem YouTube-Video von einer Zensursula-Demo auf Twitter stellt, wo man die Piratenbatterie feedet und da hat man 3000 Views. Also einfach die Macht, die das Medium auch hat.
Und das, obwohl du wahrscheinlich gar nicht... Also hast du das Video online geschenkt? Und wie viele Leute haben dir zu dem Zeitpunkt gefolgt auf Twitter?
200, irgendwas.
Aber es hat sich dann sozusagen über deine Follower wieder weiter verbreitet. Beziehungsweise hast du wahrscheinlich auch dieses Hashtag verwendet, das Zensursula.
Das bringt recht wenig, da diese Hashtags so oft benutzt werden, dass man total untergeht. Also ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, dass die meist benutzten Hashtags im Moment, also Zensursula, Iron Election sind, wenn man da irgendwas postet, bringt das Hashtag nichts, weil wenn man die Suche lässt, sowieso jeden Client abstutzt.
Da musst du vielleicht mal den Client wechseln.
Tweet hier ist schon ganz gut.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wie schätzt du denn das ein? Inwieweit hat diese Twitterrei einen Einfluss auf unsere gesellschaftliche Diskussion? Hast du den Eindruck, da jetzt mehr ein Teil davon zu sein?
Das war so bis vor einem Vierteljahr, glaube ich, da dachte auch jeder, hier ist Twitter, da sind die Nerds und die können da machen, was sie wollen. Das wird nicht wirklich wahrgenommen. Und langsam kommt es auch da oben, könnte man sagen, es gibt einige Politiker und einige Prominente, die anfangen zu twittern. Und hier, wie ich sehe, die US-amerikanische Moderatorin, die...
So heißt sie der Browser.
Und dass diese Diskussion auf Twitter langsam auch in der Gesellschaft ankommt, aber leider twittern noch viel zu wenige Leute und die meisten greifen auch diese SMS zurück. Da hab ich mal den lustigen Tweet gelesen, eine SMS ist wie Twitter, nur es kostet und man kann es nur eine Person senden.
Ja, da ist was dran. Benutzen denn viele von deinem unmittelbaren Freundeskreis auch Twitter und...
Nein, zwei Personen.
Wie reagieren die denn, wenn du sagst, du twitters jetzt, kriegst du da ablehnende Reaktionen, ist es denen egal? Oder sind die neugierig?
Ich empfohre Twitter und in der Jugendkultur ist das nicht besonders angesehen.
Leon, um dann beim Beispiel zu bleiben, da musst du noch viel Aufklärungsarbeit leisten.
Das Problem ist, dass sie auf ihren Schülerforzett Ausspül-Nadroportalen rumhängen. Und das sind einfach Niveaus, auf die man sich nicht begeben möchte.
Schön gesagt, ausdrucken, an die Wand hängen. In dem Moment kann man mal ein Stück aus dem Internet ausdrucken. Was auch spannend zu sehen ist, dass die... Was hat er seinen Twitter-Namen gar nicht gesagt, ne? Den kannst du ja noch mal schnell umzumachen, twittern.
Genau, twitter das mal an at Chaosradio. Das sollten wir vielleicht auch mal erwähnen. Also auch das Chaosradio hat natürlich einen Twitter-Account. Der Huckel hat auch einen, h-u-k-l. Und ich bin immer unter Tim Prittlaff unterwegs. Und du bist Ostbrot. Und man kann dir wahrscheinlich schon folgen. Aber ich bin gerade darauf hingewiesen worden, dass Twitter halt jetzt gerade so einen Maintenance-Modus hat. Die haben da gerade ein Problem mit dem Folgen. Das heißt, man sieht das unter Umständen erst sehr viel später. Vielleicht auch erst morgen.
Das ist ja wie Weihnachten an Auspackungen überraschend.
Was das für Folgen hat.
Was ich ganz spannend finde, ist, dass die Leute, die twittern, dass du das nicht an einer Sparte, an einer Gesellschaftsschicht oder einem Alter festmachen kannst. Das Leon sagte gerade, seine Studie Schüler, Vorzeitkollegen. Sondern dass das von 13, 14 bis 50, 60 hochgeht. Und ich hab gerade drüber nachgedacht, es gibt ja auch viele Politiker, die twittern. Ob die das freiwillig machen, weil sie es spannend finden? Oder gibt es da einen Image- und Wahlkampfberater, der sagt, es wäre eigentlich eine gute Idee, wenn du die Medien der jungen Leute benutzt?
Na, sowohl als auch, wie das immer so ist. Aber man wird da schnell entlarvt, das merkt man natürlich gleich. Also hier der schon genannte TSG hier, Schäfer-Gümbel. Dem nehme ich durchaus ab, dass er ein Interesse hat. Dann hat er halt auch wirklich mal eine Phase gehabt, wo jemand anderes auf seinem Account twittert. Das kam dann irgendwie raus, weil der, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das rauskam, irgendwie hat der, glaube ich, noch auf seinem eigenen... Ich weiß nicht, kam auf jeden Fall raus, hat er sich dann auch für entschuldigt und auch angekündigt, dass er das jetzt bleiben lässt. Es findet auch Diskussionen statt. Also hier z.B. Ranat Bütikova, Büti, auf Twitter, postet da sowohl sehr interessant als auch sehr informiert. Und da weiß ich auch, dass der das weiß, was er tut. Es gibt auch noch einige andere Beispiele. Der schon genannte Herr Taus, der jetzt aus seiner Partei da herausgemobbt wurde mit den Vorwürfen mit Kinderpornografiebesitz etc. der jetzt ausgetreten ist und zur Piratenpartei gewechselt ist. Der erlebt ja gerade seine Wiedergeburt, kann man sagen. Und auf Twitter vor allem, nicht wahr? Das ist jetzt gerade sehr spannend zu sehen, wie da jetzt wirklich ein gesellschaftspolitischer Diskurs in Echtzeit gestartet wird. Ich will das gar nicht überbewerten, aber ich will auch auf jeden Fall es nicht unterbewerten. Das hat alles Substanz. Man muss das beobachten. Es ist spannend, da jetzt dabei zu sein. Und diese Analogie, gerade mit dem Iran, das hat ja auch teilweise schon absurde Züge. Wenn man sieht, da kämpft eine unterdrückte Bürgerelite im Iran für ihre Rechte. Die einzige Möglichkeit, sich zu äußern und wahrgenommen zu werden und Hilferufe zu starten, ist das Internet. Sie kämpfen dort gegen eine Zensur und in der selben Woche wird genau eine solche Zensurinfrastruktur in Deutschland beschlossen von Politikern, die überhaupt nicht schnallen, was Sache ist. Wie wichtig es ist, die Freiheit an der Stelle, die Offenheit der Kommunikationskanäle, Informationsfreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit im Internet aufrechtzuhalten, indem man das Internet unangetastet lässt. Das ist etwas, was sich dieser Generation – es ist vor allem eine Generationenfrage hier – einfach sehr schwer erschließt. Offensichtlich, was sehr schade ist, weil das ist nun mal ganz wichtig. Und gerade in Deutschland haben wir ein Grundgesetz, was so ist, wie es ist, weil wir unserem Staat auch weiterhin misstrauen müssen. Das ist einfach ein Prinzip darauf basiert, die Integrität dieses Staates, dass man ihm einfach auch immer offen misstrauen kann und soll und ihn permanent unter Kontrolle hält.
Wenn du ihm glaubst, kannst du auch sagen, was in der Wikipedia steht, stimmt.
Stattdessen beschließen sie halt jetzt so, naja, da haben wir da so eine im Geheimen arbeitende Polizeibehörde, die Exekutive, die kann da irgendwelche Maßnahmen angreifen. Klar, das erste, was sie jetzt konkret technisch machen, das ist ja auch viel diskutiert worden, das lässt sich jetzt noch umgehen. Bloß das Ding ist, wenn das halt einmal im Rollen ist, dann kommt dann halt so, naja, wir müssen das jetzt mal ein bisschen effektiver machen und wir haben das ja schon mal beschlossen, deswegen müssen wir es nicht normal beschließen, sondern machen wir halt einfach so, weil es ja eh aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn, und dann kommen wir halt langsam wirklich dahin. Und in China ist es ja auch dasselbe Bild mit der Chinese Wall, dieser digitalen. Die kämpfen natürlich da auch um jeden Begriff und das Netz wird dort sehr kreativ und der Widerstand gegen dieses von oben verordnete Zensurprogramm, was sie da auf die Rechner installieren wollten, zeigt, dass auch in China mittlerweile ein Punkt erreicht ist, wo wir demnächst, glaube ich, auch auf eine andere Diskussionsebene gehen.
Greife mal deine Argumentationslinie auf und fasse zusammen, dass Twitter als eins der neuen Kommunikationsmedien oder als einer der Kommunikationskanäle nicht einfach nur belächelt werden sollte, als ein, Leute erzählen, ich gehe jetzt Eis essen Medium, sondern als ein Evolutionsschritt. Und das ist das Stichwort für Roland, der ist mit uns am Telefon. Hallo Roland, grüß dich.
Ja, hier ist der Roland, hallo.
Ich hoffe, ich habe dir einigermaßen richtig so getroffen, was du sagen willst.
Ja, also ich finde ja, dass Twitter einfach ein ganz billiger Dienst ist. Der kann ja gar nicht viel. Und er wurde erst zu dem, was die User daraus gemacht haben. Also wenn man sich irgendwie delicious und stumble upon, also diese Vorschlags-Seiten, was dieser Browser-Sachen da anguckt, wo man so draufklickt und man bekommt zu einem Thema eine bestimmte Seite, dann war das ja immer ganz schön. Und jetzt habe ich mich bei Twitter angemeldet, bin dem Tim Pritloff gefolgt, habe dadurch weitere Leute kennengelernt und habe dann irgendwie immer wieder neuen Input gekriegt und immer ausgesuchten Input, wo ich gesehen habe, da haben mehrere Leute getwittert, das muss interessant sein, habe ich mir das durchgelesen und bin so nochmal richtig radikalisiert worden für die zensurale Sache.
Nein, wir spielen den Song trotzdem nicht.
Ja, und inwiefern nimmst du dann selber auch aktiv dann teil, außer jetzt nur zu lesen?
Ja, ich habe das in meinem Verband installiert, sozusagen. Also wir haben uns einen so einen Verbandsaccount gemacht.
Was für ein Verband?
Die Falken, SJD die Falken, bundesweiter Kinder- und Jugendverband. Und wir gehen auch viel auf Demos und waren jetzt auf einem Bildungsstreik gewesen die letzte Woche. Und da war das ganz klasse, da sind meine Kids dann auch los mit meinem iPhone und haben dann auch eifrig getwittert, weil ich natürlich auch mal in die Uni musste und konnte die dann immer verfolgen. Das war total klasse.
Du konntest ihnen folgen. Ich finde verfolgen ist ein ganz furchtbares Wort.
Leute spotten, ich weiß, wo du mit meinem Telefon bist.
Was ich noch sagen wollte ist, dass Twitter ja auch eine super API hat. Weil es einfach so ein einfaches Programm ist, kommt man da irgendwie leicht drauf. Ich konnte dann auch diesen Mitzeichner da abonnieren und hab dann irgendwie gleich immer gesehen, wie viele Leute da unterschrieben haben. Und hat da irgendwie alles auf einem Blick, so eine personalisierte Startseite mit dem Neuesten, was es gerade gibt. Ich konnte sozusagen meine Zeitung mit den Links-Apps zusammen basteln. Das war total klasse.
Oh Gott, ich vergess mal, was ich sagen wollte. Mitzeichner, also Ed Mitzeichner, also auf Twitter. Das ist halt der, der immer so die aktuellen Petitionsstände durchgezwitschert hat. Plus interessante Links auf Artikel über den ganzen Vorfall.
Wir sind immer noch bei der Internet-Sensor.
Hat denn das dann bei euch auch im Verband jetzt zu einer Diskussion geführt? Also ist das Thema quasi jetzt auch über Twitter bei euch reingetragen worden? Oder war das auch schon vorher ein Thema? Oder ist es das gar nicht?
Ja, ich versuch das immer mal wieder reinzutun. Es hat nur so Fahrt aufgenommen und wir sind auch alle irgendwo mit der SPD mit verbunden. Und dann musste man natürlich gleich irgendwie in die SPD-Gruppe. Da gibt es ja so eine SPD-Gruppe, SPD-Mitglieder in den Piraten. Und dann ging das über Twitter, dass die es jetzt gibt. Und dann ist man da natürlich reingegangen. Und das war irgendwie, ja, man hat es irgendwie darum versucht. Weil ja, wenn man das mit Jugendlichen so durchmacht, dann muss man irgendwie erst eine Gruppenstunde vorbereiten und irgendwie so ein bisschen Inhalte haben, bevor man das Thema da durchnimmt. Und das Internet ist ja so schnell und Twitter ist ja so schnell, dass man jetzt erstmal so andere Aktionsformen da versucht hatte.
Und fragst du, also nutzt du das dann, also trittst du dann sozusagen jetzt auch bewusst in Kommunikation über Twitter, um Dinge zu hinterfragen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich Twitter, ich hab ja dann auch wieder meine Follower, die ich ja dann über so mein soziales Netzwerk kennengelernt hab. Und da retweete ich also gute Artikel, die ich auch gut fand. Dann geb ich zwischendurch Kommentare ab, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel gestern auf Hoenigs die Diskussion mit der Piratenpartei lief und misch mich dann da nochmal so in diesen Fluss ein, in diese Wolke da und gib nochmal meine Meinung da rein ins Internet.
Das soll mal dein Encounter sagen.
Oh, ich hab Varius AX.
Varius.
Ja, ansonsten schöne Sendung. Ich höre gerne CAE und mach weiter so Themen.
Alles klar. Tschüss Roland. Soviel übrigens zum Thema junge Leute, interessieren sich nicht für Politik, ne? Roland gerade das beste Beispiel dagegen.
Ja, ist ein totaler Mythos. Ist echt ein totaler Mythos.
Aber er wird ja trotzdem immer wieder weitergetragen. Auch das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann in der Welt zertweetet. Gibt es das eigentlich schon das Wort, dass ein Gerücht zertweetet wird? Also so Formulierungen, die mit Twitter und Tweets zu tun haben.
Aber vielleicht startest du ja einen neuen Trend.
Ich wollte ja hier noch mal zu den Politikern, die Twittern was sagen. Ich hatte auch die Gelegenheit schon mal an einer Konzeptionsphase für eine Politiker-Webseite mitzuwirken. Und hab da halt auch schon die andere Seite gesehen, also jetzt das Gegenbeispiel zu Taus und Bütikova und so weiter, wo dann das heißt ja, hier der Obama, der hat hier so einen Internetwahlkampf gemacht, haben wir gehört und so, war ganz erfolgreich. Und dann machen die halt so Konzepte für Webseiten, wo irgendwie alles, was nicht bei drei auf dem Bäumen ist und ein Web 2.0-Tag dran hat, halt auf die Politiker-Seite gebazzelt wird. Und die Inhalte, die dann halt übers Twitter scrollen, die sind halt auch komplett redaktionell. Das sieht man halt schon von Weitem. Also es gibt da auf jeden Fall noch so diese Generation, die sich halt wahrscheinlich auch das Twitter ausdrucken lässt. So, ja, kommen sie mal heran und zeigen sie mir die neuesten Ergebnisse vom heutigen Tag zum, äh, wie war das denn? Also soweit geht's wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, ich mein...
Aber immerhin ist das Wort Hashtag schon im Bewusstsein angekommen.
Bei denen? Bei denen bestimmt noch nicht, nee.
Ja, ja, also...
Brause, was ist noch mein Brause?
Ich wäre auch gerade hier über Twitter darauf hingewiesen, dass es sozusagen für die Politiker natürlich auch was ganz Neues ist, dass sie so eine unmittelbare Rückmeldung bekommen. Also ein positiver wie auch ein negativer Hinsicht. Was die SPD da jetzt in den letzten Tagen und Wochen hat durchmachen müssen, ich glaube, das hätten die sich auch so nicht vorstellen können. Und es geht ja da sehr schnell. Also diese Abstimmung über dieses Gesetz hatte ja dann auch interessante Kollateralschäden. Also auch, dass die Grünen sich dann zu einem Gutteil einfach enthalten haben, nicht dagegen gestimmt haben. Das ist ihnen auch ganz kräftig um die Ohren geflogen. Und alle sind, glaube ich, von dieser Dynamik sehr überrascht. Aber wer das jetzt eben auch für sich zu nutzen weiß und dann eben auch eine Diskussion auf gleicher Augenhöhe führt, der hat auch gute Chancen, da zu bestehen. Gerade dieses auf einer Augenhöhe ist ein wichtiges Element, was man bei Twitter bedenken muss. Während man so bei Blogs... Klar, da gab es ja auch schon diese Möglichkeit, Rückmeldungen zu machen. Aber du hast immer diesen Unterschied, immer diese asynchrone Positionierung. Da ist derjenige, der die Blogartikel schreibt und die anderen sind so die Kommentatoren. Aber auf Twitter ist ja auch eine Antwort auf einen Tweet. Einfach ein Tweet, wie jeder andere auch, der genauso im selben Universum wiederum von anderen gelesen und wiederum verlinkt und beantwortet werden kann. Und das macht, glaube ich, auch einen großen Unterschied aus in der Kommunikation.
Und es ist dann, dass da wir nochmal zum Anfangsthema eigentlich zu kommen, die Twitter und was es gesellschaftlich bewirken kann, was es in dieser Welt kann als Tool, wenn ich das so formulieren darf, ist es natürlich schon eine Stufe höher auf der Demokratisierung oder auf der demokratischen Diskussion, als bei Maybrit Illner oder wem auch immer im Studio als Studiogast zu sitzen. Vorne sitzen Politiker und du darfst vielleicht mal eine Frage stellen. Du bist viel direkter in der Diskussion dabei. Das ist das, was du eben sagtest, dass die Politiker sich auch plötzlich einer ganz neuen Diskussionswand gegenüber sehen.
Ja und die Leute, die dann Fragen fragen, das sind ja auch irgendwie vorausgesuchte gebriefte, was weiß ich, teilweise dann gab es ja diese absurde Townhall-Simulation. Das gibt es auch in amerikanischen Politik gibt es diese Townhall-Meetings, wo dann wirklich, keine Ahnung, Obama, wer auch immer, steht da vorne rum und dann kommen die Leute und fragen halt. Das ist ein offenes Diskussionsforum. Dann haben sie irgendwie versucht, das mit der Merkel irgendwie nachzuspielen, völlig gestaged. Die Leute, die da geredet haben, über die wurden dann ja auch noch Videos vorher eingespielt. Also bekloppter kann man ja nun wirklich nicht darauf hinweisen, dass das einfach alles durch und durch Medien kontrolliert ist.
Sie wollten es aber ganz richtig machen wahrscheinlich. So, dass es richtig gut und modern aussieht.
Ja, aber genau damit landen sie halt an der falschen Stelle. Und das begreifen die sehr, sehr, sehr langsam. Auch wie die SPD im Vorfeld der Gesetzesabstufung. Die Woche vorher hatten ja noch ihren blöden Parteitag, wo sie dann irgendwie diesen Steinmeier da irgendwie verjubelt haben. Und den Antrag doch nochmal über diese Gesetzgeschichte zu debattieren, beziehungsweise auch zu einer Abstimmung zu kommen, der wurde dann abgebügelt mit einer geilen Formulierung, das sei medial unerwünscht. Und glaube, das ist wirklich das, was ihnen jetzt gerade echt auf den Fuß fallen wird. Dieses medial unerwünscht, das endet jetzt langsam, diese Ära, wo sie sich einfach ihre mediale Darstellung so zusammenwünschen können, wie sie es wollen. Sind sie wirklich gezwungen, da den harten Boxfight auszuhalten? Mit ihrem Volk, das steckt jetzt zurück.
0331 70 97 110, das ist die Telefonnummer hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Wir machen kurz mal eine elektronische Zeitansage. Oldschool, so Zeit 1.0. Und warum Oldschool 1.0? Weil die Zeit müssen wir ansagen. Es ist Punkt 11. Willkommen im Chaosradio. Huckel ist hier, Tim ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden heute über Twitter und der nächste am Telefon ist René. Hallo René, guten Abend. Von wo rufst du an?
Ich ruf aus Ravensburg an.
Aus Ravensburg? Okay. Und wie alt bist du?
Ich bin 26.
Seit wann nutzt du Twitter?
Ja gut, ich hab grad mal nachgeguckt, während ich gewartet hab. Angemeldet hab ich mich glaube ich im Juni letzten Jahres.
Warum?
Da hab ich noch nicht so nix gemacht. Also da hab ich mich auch gefragt, wozu das gut sein soll, weil ein Kollege mir das empfohlen hat und da dachte ich SMS verschicken.
Das ist bei allen so am Anfang.
Also ich hab grad nochmal geguckt.
Also im November hab ich dann angefangen, das mehr zu nutzen.
Also du hast es erstmal ein gutes Vierteljahr skeptisch beäugt.
Ja genau, also ich hatte quasi meinen Kollegen, der mir das empfohlen hat, den hatte ich als Kontakts und dann war das so. Und dann hab ich im November irgendwie erst nochmal durch den Zweiten darauf und dann nahm das halt seinen Lauf. Also inzwischen auch täglich und erste Informationsquelle, sag ich mal.
Und was gewinnst du dann für Informationen daraus?
Ich finde, das kommt doch mal drauf an, nach was man sucht. Also wenn ich jetzt, was weiß ich, mich informieren will, was das heute passiert, dann guck ich Nachrichten. Und wenn ich aber jetzt zum Beispiel wissen will, was jetzt bei den Themen passiert ist, die sind die letzten drei Wochen so in dieser, quasi so schwer. Also sei es jetzt Iran oder ist es diese Zensursula-Debatte, dann ist Twitter, finde ich, das bessere Medium. Also oder der Einstieg besser.
Wie nimmst du die Iransache wahr?
Das kann ich schwer einschätzen. Also ich bin da nicht so beteiligt. Also ich kann ja zu nichts sagen. Ich weiß nicht, was da wirklich wahr ist. Was nicht. Also ich finde das großartig, dass das da funktioniert und nochmal zurückgeht. Vorhin hat man wohl gesagt, dass der Twitter-Dienst extra seine Wartungsmaschine verschoben hat. Da hatte ich letzte Woche einen Podcast gehört, der H2 der Tag.
Übrigens sehr zu empfehlen.
Ja, da meinten sie, dass das sogar das Gerücht gibt, dass das aufgrund vom amerikanischen Außenministerium angestoßen wurde, dass die das doch bitte verschieben würden wollen.
Ja, das ist bestätigt.
Also das war jetzt nicht der Präsident, der da angerufen hat. Das kam irgendwie aus dem White House irgendwo. Da haben sie halt gesagt, das müsst ihr jetzt nicht unbedingt machen, während da gerade die Demos laufen, sondern macht das mal so, dass das eben jetzt nachts in Iran ist.
Wofür dann die Amerikaner ein bisschen Maintenance-Zeit hinnehmen mussten?
Genau, aber da hat sich dann auch wirklich so recht keiner beschwert drüber.
Aber hier über diese Iran-Geschichte im Speziellen, das hast du ja auch schon ganz richtig erkannt, dass man da auch nicht so richtig sagen kann, was jetzt war oder was falsch ist. Aber was mich da auch sehr fasziniert hat, ist einfach die Fülle der Information und dass es eben auch von allen Seiten kommt. Also es war ja am Anfang sehr aus einer Richtung, sozusagen von den Demonstranten. Und dann kam es halt immer mehr so Tweets dazwischen, so jetzt twittert die Regierung mit und jetzt glaubt man nicht allen, die da was twittern, sondern nur denen, die schon länger twittern und nicht die gestern ersten Account gemacht haben.
Was vielleicht auch bei Iran-Elektrischen, im Gegensatz zu den Zenzursula jetzt als Hashtag, das Problem ist, da wird man echt überfrachtet. Also da twittert ja, sag ich mal, die ganze Welt und bei Zenzursula ist es, ich sag jetzt mal, nur Deutschland.
Ja und das wird halt aber auch alles getwittert, das ganze Spektrum der Information. Also die einen, die posten halt ein Video von einem, der jemandem den Kopf schießt, in Anführungsstrichen, ja und die anderen posten halt Propaganda von wegen, das ist jetzt hier alles gar nicht wahr und Photoshoppen halt irgendwelche Demofotos und laden die hoch. Und man kann halt sich eigentlich auch gar nicht so richtig ein Bild machen, aber es ist trotzdem für mich zumindest sehr faszinierend zu sehen, einfach dieses Spektrum an Information, was da kontinuierlich durch den Kleinen scrollt und man einfach alles kriegt und nicht eben nur das, was CNN jetzt in fünf Minuten Beitrag mal zusammengeschnippelt hat.
Und es lässt dich mit jedem Tweet, den du liest, immer wieder realisieren, dass du nichts glaubst, so wie es auf deinem Bildschirm oder wo auch immer steht, sondern dass du bitte alles hinterfragst.
Genau.
Und immer skeptisch bist über Infos, die dir irgendjemand als gesetzt gibt.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall auch sehr lehrreich, so was zu beobachten, so diesen Informationskrieg live und in Farbe sozusagen.
Ja, ich finde bei Twitter, da kann man auch sehen, wer jetzt eigentlich die Telekommunikation verstanden hat und wer nicht. Ihr hattet das Beispiel mit der SPD, die hat es einfach. Oder die großen Parteien jetzt, ich möchte die SPD da jetzt nicht. Große Vorhaben, die haben es einfach irgendwie verkackt. Ich fand da letzte Woche, das ist auch so ein Punkt, was ich bei Twitter faszinierend finde, da war ja letzte Woche die Diskussion vor der Abstimmung mit dieser Censursular Debatte da, wo die Werte vorher nicht mal anwesend war. Was ich super finde, ist, wenn man auf Fernsehen schaut, solche Debatten und dabei Twitter verfolgt. Also das ist super mitzulesen. Der Taus hat ja glaube ich direkt getwittert von dort. Dann der Max, der auch von schon zitiert wurde. Ich finde das ist super.
Ja, Max saß im Publikum.
Ich finde das super, wenn ich abends vom Fernseher sitze oder abends nach Hause komme, mache den Fernseher an und kann den. Also früher, ich gucke Fernsehen, sehe solche Debatte und denke mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Und jetzt kann ich direkt bei Twitter mich austauschen und sehe, Gott sei Dank bist du nicht allein.
Genau, das hatten wir vorhin auch schon mal das Gefühl, dass du da nicht alleine bist mit einer Meinung.
Ein kollektives Pfeifen im Wald. Womit man nicht hoffen kann, eine scherzhafte, kollektives Zwitschern im Wald.
Es ist ja auch noch ein ganz interessantes Feature, ich weiß nicht, das hatten wir noch nicht erwähnt, dass man ja die Tweets auch geokodieren kann. Also wenn man zum Beispiel mit dem Mobiltelefon unterwegs ist, dass dann auch deine Koordinaten, wo du gerade bist, mitgeteetet werden können, nicht müssen. So dass zum einen in dem viel zitierten Iran-Beispiel halt die Leute gesagt haben, folgt man wirklich nur den Leuten, die halt auch wirklich in Teheran sind, von den Koordinaten her. Aber ich zum Beispiel hatte auch letztens hier als Tempelhofbesetzung war. Ich wohne da in der Nähe, habe ich dann einfach auch in meinem iPhone mal geklickt. Irgendwie gib mir mal alle Tweets jetzt hier aus 5 km Umgebung und hab dann halt auch dieses Foto von diesem Zivilpolizisten, der da die Knarre zieht, das scrollte da als erstes bei mir im Twitter durch. Weil es einfach in der Nähe war. Und das ist halt eben auch dieses Bahnhofsfeature, was wir vorhin schon hatten.
Der Zug fährt nicht los und keiner sagt dir warum, Twitter sagt es dir dann.
Genau, also das ist halt auch ein echt nettes Feature mit diesen Geokoordinaten.
Lässt sich eigentlich, du hattest gerade erwähnt mit folgt nur den Leuten, die wirklich eine Geoposition im Iran oder Afghanistan oder so, die das da haben, lässt sich das irgendwie manipulieren? Weil die Diskussion ist ja immer wieder da, dass Leute sagen, das kann gar nicht stimmen und ich glaub denen das nicht. Könntest du jetzt von hier aus im Fritz-Studio mit Kraft deines technischen Know-Hows deine Koordinaten so verändern, dass ich glauben würde, du sitzt in Bayern?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall alles andere als unmöglich, ja. Also der Otto-Normalt-Vitera, der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht irgendwie so in sich mal schnell einen Skript hacken, was halt die Geokoordinaten da forcht, also falsche Koordinaten.
Du kannst da eintragen, was du willst, das ist kein sicherer Kenntnis und gerade jetzt im Fall Teheran ist das natürlich jetzt auch gerade ein echtes Problem. Es ging ja wie eine Welle auch wieder durch Twitter, dass man doch bitte als Ort selbst jeder Teheran einstellen soll, damit einfach die Leute, die jetzt wirklich da sind oder sich vorher als dort verortet haben, dem Staat, also den Behörden, die sozusagen gerade auf der Spur sind, nicht auffallen. Ja, wir sind alle Iraner, also das ist das alles sozusagen so eine Nebelwolke.
Und das vor allen Dingen alles innerhalb von weniger als 24 Stunden. Also erst die Entwicklung, jetzt folgt man hier allen aus Teheran und dann oh Moment, keine gute Idee.
Viele sagen auch, wenn ihr irgendwas retweetet, wo ihr wisst, das kommt aus dem Iran, lasst den Namen weg, auch wenn das normalerweise dabei ist, um nicht sozusagen die Quelle zu erschlagen. Und sie kriegen auch aktive Hilfe, auch über Twitter, in dem halt Proxys zugespielt werden, das wird mittlerweile auch nicht mehr öffentlich gemacht, sondern es geht über verschlungene Pfaden. Es gibt halt bestimmte Twitterer, denen man sozusagen vertraut, wo man auch weiß, dass da der Account nicht gehackt wurde, denen werden dann halt Sachen gesteckt und die finden dann natürlich untereinander auch noch andere Wege. Das ist wirklich unglaublich spannend. Wir wissen alle nicht, wie es ausgeht. Wir wissen natürlich auch nicht, welche Dimension es wirklich hat. Aber es ist ganz unzweifelhaft so, dass da jetzt einfach gerade was abgeht, was man so noch nie erlebt hat.
Und das Gefühl, was wir alle haben, wir wissen zu wenig. Du kriegst nicht das mit, weil du willst immer mehr wissen. Es passiert immer wieder, dass dieselbe Meldung nochmal und nochmal und nochmal durchgekaut wird mit dem Experten, der um vier Ecken sitzt, dann nochmal von der anderen Seite beleuchtet wird. Aber sie reden immer noch über das selbe. Du hast das Gefühl, erzähl mir bitte irgendwas Neues. Zum Thema Twitter und Iran haben wir noch Jan am Telefon. Hallo Jan, grüß dich, guten Abend. Hallo.
Ja, ich nutze Twitter eigentlich auch erst seit Kurzem, weil ich immer dachte, um das gescheit machen zu können, da das in Deutschland ja mit SMS nicht geht, braucht man ein Smartphone. Das hatte ich lange Zeit nicht, nun habe ich eins. Und ich bin eigentlich relativ begeistert. Zum einen ist es halt sehr praktisch hier für lokale Aktivitäten und zum anderen eben halt das Thema Iran. Da ist natürlich das eine, man weiß halt nicht genau, ist das jetzt eine authentische Information eben genau dadurch, dass man denjenigen, die man folgt, nicht persönlich kennt und das überhaupt nicht einordnen kann, wenn das genau ist.
Wie nimmst du jetzt sozusagen Teil an Twitter? Liest du vor allem? Schreibst du was?
Beides. Überwiegend lesen momentan. Kommt halt dadurch, dass ich noch relativ neu bin und jetzt auch noch nicht irgendwie...
Das ist immer sehr ratsam, wenn man sich einem neuen Medium nähert, erst mal zu lesen, bevor man schreibt.
Ich soll mal so wie Holgi lachen.
Und wie findest du, also über welche Leute bist du eingestiegen? Wie hast du sozusagen deinen Anfang gemacht? Wem folgst du und woher bekommst du diese Information, wem du folgen könntest?
Ja, das wurde ja immer mehr Thema. Und dann hatte ich halt auch ein Smartphone jetzt. Und dann habe ich das einfach mal angefangen. Und einstieg dann über eine Mailing-Liste, erst mal so in meinem persönlichen Umfeld, was mich so interessiert, da erst mal gefragt, hallo wer twittert und das und das und da könnt ihr folgen und meldet euch mal.
Also über deine Freunde, sozusagen.
Genau.
Und nutzt ihr das dann auch innerhalb eures Freundeskreises so für private Aktivitäten? Party, Verabredungen?
Noch relativ eingeschränkt. Ich denke mal, das hängt einfach damit zusammen, dass noch nicht jeder so ein Smartphone hat. Weil ich glaube in Deutschland, um es vernünftig nutzen zu können, braucht es einfach ein Smartphone. Gerade auch wenn man irgendwelchen Links oder so, dann tut es eine SMS oder so ja doch nicht, wobei das ja in Deutschland auch wieder nicht geht. Also ohne Smartphone, glaube ich, verliert das sehr viel an Wert.
Na gut, aber man kann es ja auch an seinem Rechner machen.
Ja, sicherlich. Aber dann hat man halt diesen Aktualitätsbonus nicht. Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie abends oder so am Rechner sitzt, dann gibt es ja doch bessere Möglichkeiten als 140 Zeichen, obwohl sich auch damit schon sehr viel sagen lässt.
Wobei ja es auch ganz viele Leute gibt, die tatsächlich so einen Bürojob am Computer haben und den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzen.
Da muss ich sagen, bei uns auf der Arbeit habe ich zum Beispiel ein Proxy, die sperren doch tatsächlich Twitter. Da bin ich ja schockiert.
Aber du kannst auch Twitter auch über HTTPS benutzen, das werden sie bestimmt nicht durch ihren Proxy kriegen. Und da man HTTPS schon ab und zu mal braucht, ist das meistens kein Problem. Nur mal so als Tipp. Interessanter Punkt, was diese Unsperrbarkeit jetzt im Iran von Twitter betrifft. Man könnte ja sagen, wieso machen die nicht einfach Twitter zu? Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es da aussieht. Ich denke mir, das Twitter-Portal als solches dürfte da definitiv nicht zu erreichen sein. Aber es gibt ja viele andere Wege. Das wurde ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen. Diese API, diese Programmschnittstellen. Das heißt, man hat ein Programm auf seinem eigenen Rechner laufen und das redet halt mit dem Twitter. Und da gibt es eben viele Wege, die da hinfügen. Und andere Webseiten können mir auch einen Zugang zu Twitter bieten, indem sie mir halt ein Webinterface bieten und ich twittere dort und die schmeißen das hinten rein. Und das ist halt der Grund, warum Twitter da auch derzeit so nicht zu stoppen ist.
Gesetzt den Fall, jetzt das Szenario gesponnen, sollten sie Twitter abschalten oder irgendwie sperren, wird natürlich die twitternde Gemeinde, wird sich das ganz schnell rumsprechen und der Link zur Abhilfe ist innerhalb von Sekunden bei dir.
Jaja, trotzdem. Ich meine, man darf sich jetzt auch nicht der Illusion hingeben, dass man überall drumherum kommt. Diese Zensur, diese Internetzensur im Iran, ist da auf jeden Fall ein Problem.
Das ist ja auch von Deutschland gelieferte Technik.
Teilweise Siemens, Nokia, Konglomerat, den Firmen haben jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau im Kopf.
Wo hast du denn diese Information her? Aus dem Internet etwa?
Hast du auf Twitter gelesen, ne?
Das ist ja nicht per se eine schlechte Informationsquelle, im Gegenteil.
Okay, aber feil an der Halbwissen.
Ja, wie auch immer. Es ist vollkommen klar. Ja, also ich meine, dass es diese Sperrtechniken gibt und dass die in Deutschland genauso wie in den USA und überall hergestellt werden, das ist ja auch kein Geheimnis. Also diese Technologie ist verfügbar und sie wird halt auch immer wieder so mit diesem Argument Kinderschutz natürlich auch gerne verkauft, was ja auch jetzt gerade diese Maßnahme hier mit diesem KIPO-Gesetz so per viele macht. Weil man damit halt immer alles verkaufen kann und immer glaubt, keiner würde sich wehren. Und es wehrt sich auf einmal das Netz trotzdem und alle sind überrascht. Wie, was, ihr wollt das diskutieren? Sowas wird doch nicht diskutiert. Doch, wir diskutieren das jetzt. Und zwar in aller Öffentlichkeit und mit einer Bandbreite. Dieser schöne Tweet, der vorhin schon genannt wurde, den Max mal gebracht hat. Ihr werdet euch noch wünschen, wir werden Politik verdrossen.
Zu dem Thema Twitter gibt ein neues Level in Sachen Demokratie. Holen wir uns nochmal Sandra ins Boot. Jan und René, euch beide schicke ich jetzt in die Nacht. Tschüss, danke für den Anruf. Ihr seid übrigens im Chaosradio auf Fritz03317097110 und die nächste haben Telefone Sandra. Guten Abend Sandra. Zum Thema Twitter und Demokratie. Holen wir dich mit ins Boot. Was möchtest du sagen?
Genau, da ist mir letztens ein Tweet aufgefallen von jemandem, der gesagt hat, Twitter ist eine Blase.
Eine Blase?
Eine Blase. Wir sind ja alle in dem Twitter drin und merken das alles und bekommen die ganzen Tweets mit. Aber ganz, ganz viele Leute außerhalb des Internets oder sagen wir mal Leute, die nur eine Stunde am Tag im Internet sind, die bekommen überhaupt nicht mit, was da alles passiert. Und die spricht man dann oft in Sosula an oder auf Iran-Election oder sowas und dann sagen die, ja, keine Ahnung, was ist da passiert? Oder sagen halt, ja, das hab ich auch gelesen in der Zeitung. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, das ist nur in Twitter so richtig gehypt und ansonsten bekommen die Leute das kaum mit, halt nur noch über Medien.
Aber wir beobachten ja auch, dass Twitter jetzt in zunehmendem Maße auch für die normalen Medien die Quelle wird. Da gab es diese schöne Tagesschau, da mit dem Iran, wo sie meinten so, ja, man kann das ja immer alles nicht überprüfen. Es ist auch so lustig, wie sie immer darauf hinweisen, ja, das sind ja alles so Quellen, da weiß man ja nicht, ob es stimmt. Als ob das jetzt beim normalen Fernsehen jemals anders gewesen wäre. Wer glaubt, was im Fernsehen gebracht wird, dem gehört auch mal der Kopf gewaschen. Das ist einfach eine genauso unzuverlässige Quelle. Und dieses ganze Gewusel, man muss ja das alles zweimal lesen. Das kann ich jedem nur raten, wenn man auch die traditionellen Medien konsumiert. Auch Chaosradio. Und das wird natürlich jetzt sehr deutlich. Ich finde es sehr gut, dass sich jetzt herumgesprochen hat, dass man vielleicht auch mal seine Quellen selber checken sollte. Und Hirn einschalten ist generell immer zu empfehlen. Schön fand ich dann auch diesen Spruch in der Tagesschau, als sie dann diese Videos zeigen, da sie ja selber nichts in der Hand hatten. Alle ihre Journalisten wurden dann des Landes verwiesen oder durften nicht mehr den Raum verlassen. Dann so, ja, wir zeigen jetzt Videos, die es bisher so nur im Internet zu sehen gab. Da müssen wir gleich lachen, so, ha ha, nur im Internet, ihr seid ja lustig, ist klar. Das zeigt natürlich auch deutlich, wie diese Wahrnehmung ist. Aber ich denke, das ändert sich jetzt. Denkst du das nicht auch?
Unterschiedlich, also es sind vor allen Dingen halt die höheren Schichten, die gewilderten Leute, die halt das Internet richtig nutzen, vielleicht richtig, die das Internet überhaupt nutzen. Und alle anderen, die vielleicht in der Schule mal ins Internet können, die sind dann irgendwie ausgeschlossen. Die dann halt zu StudiVZ gehen oder zu Facebook, oder was weiß ich nicht alles.
Wir holen an der Stelle mal die Generation StudiVZ Facebook mit ins Boot. Wir haben Alexander am Telefon, der ist 18. Und der will was sagen zu der twitternden und der nicht twitternden Bevölkerung. Hallo Alexander. Grüß dich. Das was Samra gerade sagt, würdest du da mitgehen? Dass Twitter eine Blase ist? Dass Twitter eine Blase ist und dass die, die drin sind, das alles super finden und die, die draußen sind, kriegen es nicht mit?
Also ich bin jetzt seit über ein Jahr dabei bei Twitter und ganz am Anfang sowieso. Also ganz kleine Blase. Aber mittlerweile merkt man es auch schon, dass auch immer mehr in den Zeitungen, zum Beispiel bei Die Welt und so, kommt es jetzt immer mehr, dass zum Beispiel Tweet des Tages und sowas gibt es jetzt da auch schon. Und meine Mutter kommt auch rein und sagt, ja, hallo, heute in Twitter, da war irgendwie ein Virus oder so. Und dann sag ich, hä? Und man merkt halt, es kommt immer mehr in die, in die normale Gesellschaft halt auch mit rein. Aber es ist in gewisser Weise immer noch eine Blase mit ein paar kleinen Löchern.
Ich bekomme übrigens gerade auch ein Tweet, das unter Fashion-Bloggern angeblich auch sehr beliebt ist, um neueste Fashion-Trends zu verfolgen. Also ich sehe das ja auch so, aber prinzipiell ist es auch so, ich meine, die Leute, die halt nur Bildzeitungen lesen wollen, die lesen halt nur Bildzeitungen. Und die Leute, die ein bisschen mehr Interesse haben, die kaufen sich halt mal die Zeit oder noch eine andere Zeitung und lesen halt auch quer. Also das würde ich jetzt gar nicht mal so aufs Medium beschränken, sondern das ist halt einfach ein generelles Interesse. Will ich wirklich wissen, was da ist oder reicht mir, wenn ich jetzt hier auf Seite 1 der Mädel sehe und noch den Wetterbericht habe?
Wie viel deiner Zeit würdest du weggeben, um dich mit so viel Information zu versorgen, dass du dich informiert fühlst? Ich? Nee, aber das ist so die Frage, die da so dahinter steht. Alexander, wie ist das so in deinem Umfeld? Bei deinen Freunden oder bei den Leuten, die aus der Schule sind die auch bei Twitter oder ist das eher so die Studi-VZ-Abteilung?
Leider. Also von meiner Ausbildung hier in der Berufsschule kommen jetzt aus meiner Berufsklasse 1, 2, schön langsam dazu. Also es ist alles sehr fließend. Ich sehe da noch nicht so den Hype in der normalen Bevölkerung, dass das jetzt halt immer mehr kommt. In den USA ist ja anscheinend um einiges mehr als bei uns jetzt hier in Deutschland. Und ich muss auch sagen, viele sagen halt einfach erstmal, hä, was ist denn Twitter oder auch jetzt mit der Zensursala-Diskussion. Die haben das auch gar nicht so mitgekriegt, auch wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so einen Beruf hat wie Fachinformatiker. Wenn ich damit mit Leuten rede über die Zensur-Debatte, ich habe mir den Mund fußlich geredet, wochenlang da jetzt halt hier die Petition und so und die haben halt gesagt, interessiert mich doch nicht und brauche ich mich, hab doch Internet und ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen, immer diese berühmten Kastanen. Und ich bin halt der Meinung, dass man sich halt auch politisch ein bisschen engagieren soll und auch ruhig seine Grundgesetze wahrhaben sollte und zwar das mit der Meinungsfreiheit. Auch wenn es jetzt erstmal so ist, meine Freundin hat neulich mal irgendwie in meinen Blog geschaut und da meinte sie so, hey, was, du bloggst ja hier über Politik und so, ist das dann jetzt nicht schlecht, wenn da mal jemand einstellen möchte. Da steht dann deine politische Aussage drin.
Aber sprichst du mit deiner Freundin im Real Life nicht auch über Politik? Ist dir das komplett neu, dass du das im Netz machst?
Nee, nee, das mach ich schon auch mit ihr. Aber im Netz ist es halt für alle. Das war halt das, was sie eher so abgeschreckt hat, denke ich mal. Und ich bin aber schon der Meinung, dass man halt seine politische Meinung oder die Diskussion über diese Themen auch ruhig öffentlich machen soll und nicht nur halt immer im kleinen Kreis, vielleicht nur Familie oder so, am Abend-Tisch, am Stammtisch irgendwie. Und dann passiert sowieso nichts, weil jeder meint, das ist so und so. Und dann kommt danach nichts dabei raus, weil es war halt bloß eine Gruppe von zehn Leuten oder so. Und so trägt man das halt an die Öffentlichkeit halt auch. Und man sieht es jetzt auch bei Twitter, da hat ja die Petition, die hat ja über Twitter einen Hype bekommen. Das war ja echt ein Wahnsinn. Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich fand es auch richtig toll zu sehen, dass man halt, wie Sie schon mehrere gesagt haben, man ist halt nicht alleine mit seiner Meinung. Und das Medium Twitter, das unterstützt einen das sehr, halt auch über sowas zu diskutieren und Meinungen auszutauschen.
Zu diesem Hinweis mit irgendwie ja, die allgemeine Bevölkerung und so. Klar, dass ist natürlich, dass der Großteil der Leute in unserer Gesellschaft nicht bereit ist, in solchen Diskussionen teilzunehmen und schon gar nicht bereit ist, im Internet an solchen Diskussionen teilzunehmen. Das wissen wir alle. Das ist auch etwas, was sich jetzt durch den Generationenwandel auf gewisse Art und Weise von alleine löst. Was ich aber ganz interessant finde ist, dass jetzt eben durch, nicht nur durch Twitter, es ist mir auch alles ein bisschen zu Twitter zentriert. Es gibt natürlich auch noch andere, wir gehen auch nochmal drauf ein. Aber was halt jetzt sozusagen diese neue, noch nähere Vernetzung bewirkt ist, dass eben diese Elite, die sehr wohl bereit ist, sich inhaltlich zu engagieren und zu diskutieren, dass die jetzt auch eine Plattform dafür hat, das zu tun und sie tut es dann eben auch. Und das ist natürlich viel wichtiger, weil letzten Endes wird diese Gesellschaft von Eliten gesteuert und es gibt da halt Eliten, die sind halt einfach daran interessiert, dass der Status quo erhalten bleibt. Und es gibt eben eine neue Elite, die eben damit nicht einverstanden ist. Und da finden ja auch die Auseinandersetzungen tatsächlich statt. Man muss nicht jetzt jeden auf Twitter zerren. Aber wichtig ist, dass man die Multiplikatoren, die Leute, die eine Meinung haben und die auch bereit sind, sie zu diskutieren und zu vertreten, dass man die eben mit in die Diskussionsrunde wirft. Und die Möglichkeit gibt es jetzt in zunehmendem Maße.
Ich würde auch sowieso nicht sagen, dass jetzt halt Twitter für alle Zeiten das Allheilmittel ist. Also sagen wir mal, Twitter wird morgen verkauft und dann ist alles ganz blöd. Dann gibt es halt den nächsten Service. Und der ist dann vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen besser. Und ich sehe da halt einfach generell den Trend, dass den Sieg ist zu des Web, sozusagen das Mitmach-Webs. Dass es einfach immer einfacher wird, sich selbst zu broadcasten und sich mit anderen zu vernetzen. Und Twitter ist halt jetzt einfach gerade das Medium, was am größten ist und am aktivsten. Und das wird sich bestimmt auch nochmal ändern.
Es gab auch Zeiten noch, da haben die Leute gesagt, wozu brauche ich denn auf meinem Mobiltelefon die Möglichkeit, da eine kurze Textnachricht zu verschicken. Ich kann ja auch anrufen, das brauche ich alles auch nicht. Mittlerweile ist das ein normaler Teil unseres Lebens. Und so wird es mit Twitter irgendwann auch sein. Damit sind wir nochmal bei der Blase, wo ihr sagt, wir sind jetzt noch in diesem Luftballon drin. Und der Rest der Welt ist da draußen.
Die Blase wird größer.
Wir können alle nicht in die Zukunft gucken, vielleicht gibt es irgendwann etwas mit Fashionbloggern oder mit Süßigkeiten, ich habe keine Ahnung, mit irgendwas vollkommen Banalem zu tun hat, wo die Welt sagt, super, das kann man mit Twitter machen sofort. Wo mich dann mein Vater anrufen würde und würde sagen, wie geht das wirklich machen?
Genau, das ist doch die richtige Strategie, den Leuten das mitzugeben. Also das, was im Internet diskutiert wird, auf die Straße zu tragen, in die Familie zu tragen, in die Schule, in die Uni zu treiben, wo auch immer hin.
Und das ist ja auch sehr schön, an dieser ganzen Diskursion, gerade bei Zensur, ich hab das jetzt bei vielen hier auch schon zwischen den Zeilen rausgelesen. Und ich hab das auch sehr häufig gehört. Viele nehmen halt über Twitter oder was auch immer an dieser Debatte teil und fühlen sich einmal hochmotiviert zu dieses, wir sind nicht allein, ja, fühlen sich hochmotiviert, das in ihre Familien, ihre Peer-Gruppen, ihren Freundeskreis, ihre Firma, was auch immer reinzutragen. Natürlich mit gemischtem Erfolg, wie das immer so ist, aber der Erfolg ist natürlich definitiv größer, wenn das getan wird, als wenn es komplett unterlassen werden würde. Das hat auch, glaube ich, zu dem Erfolg dieser Online-Petition beigetragen. Und das wird dann auch in zunehmendem Maße dazu beitragen, dass diese Diskussion auch weitergeht. Wird jetzt sehr spannend, zum Beispiel, gerade bei der Zellensurseler Debatte. Man könnte ja sagen, das ist ja jetzt vorbei, das Gesetz ist ja beschlossen. Zwei Tage später geht das weiter mit bundesweiten Demonstrationen. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass sich das Ganze noch mal bis zur Bundestagswahl in irgendeiner Form trägt.
Hier wird jetzt, also ich weiß nicht, wollen wir ja noch kurz mal nur, damit was gesagt haben, noch die anderen Dienste mal kurz abhandeln. Also nachgucken könnt ihr dann selber bei Wikipedia, was das macht. Also es gibt halt noch einen großen anderen, der heißt Identica. Und dahinter steht auch ein Open Source System, was ihr euch dann selber auch auf dem Server installieren könnt. Dann gibt es noch Jaiku. Und irgendwas...
Gibt es das noch? Nee, ich glaube, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr? Schon verkauft?
Was gibt es noch?
Also es guckt einfach, wenn er bei Twitter auf Wikipedia guckt, dann kriegt er auch die alternativen Dienste.
Also Twitter, es gibt ja auch einen technischen Begriff für Twitter. Der wird wenig bemüht. Microblogging. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen das, was Twitter tut. Und es verdichtet sich halt jetzt alles auf Twitter, weil natürlich allein das Microblogging, nur der Dienst als solcher, ist ja erstmal nichts ohne die Leute. Und so wie sich es eben entwickelt hat, dadurch, dass Twitter eben auch die ersten waren, und sie auch genug getan haben, um selbst am Ball der Leute, die es benutzen, dran zu bleiben, ist es einfach jetzt der Ort, wo alle sind. Das kann man gut finden, das kann man schlecht finden, aber es ist einfach ein Fakt. Und das macht eben diesen Kanal so wertvoll.
Und die Vergrößerung des Mediums, oder die Vergrößerung des Kanals, hängt sicherlich auch damit zusammen, wie schnell es möglich ist, Internet überall hin mitzunehmen. Weil klar, kannst du mit dem Smartphone irgendwie dein Internet mitnehmen, jeder hat so ein Ding, es geht nicht überall. Viele müssen an den Rechner, wo das Internet dran ist, um sich dann da damit zu beschäftigen. Das heißt, du kannst nicht einfach mal aus der Straße oder in der Region dich irgendwie da einloggen und gucken, wie es funktioniert. Aber auch das ist eine technische Entwicklung, die vorwärts geht und die hoffentlich in den nächsten Jahren dann...
In Iran lief es ja auch so, dass sie dann einfach Leute lokal angerufen haben, wo sie wussten, die haben jetzt einen Nachbarn mit Internet und haben das dann halt so über drei Ecken weitergetragen.
Aber es ist schön zu sehen, wie einfach der technische Fortschrift an der Stelle auch wieder greift. Was vorhin erwähnt wurde, die Sendung von hr2dertag, die du gelobt hast, ich lobe die auch gleich nochmal, die sind übrigens auch auf Twitter jetzt mit der Tag, derzeit nur Ankündigung, mal gucken, vielleicht kann man mit denen auch bald mal diskutieren. Die haben dann auch nochmal so diesen Rückblick gemacht, wie denn das eigentlich bei der ersten oder bei der letzten Revolution im Iran gelaufen ist, also als Khomeini an die Macht kam. Und das Interessante war, dass die Botschaften, also damals war ja im Prinzip genau die gleiche Situation. Da war halt der Shah, Esar-Esa Pahlavi, der hat halt alles unter Kontrolle gehabt und die Medien und so weiter, mit Ausnahme der Moscheen. Und die Botschaften von Khomeini, seine Reden, wurden mit Magnetbändern, also mit Tapes, ins Land gebracht und dann eben kopiert und eben verteilt. Und das hat eben dazu geführt, dass eben, ja das war sozusagen, also das Twitter der frühen 80er-Jahre war halt das Magnetband, der Kompaktkassette. Und jetzt ist halt das Internet.
Machen wir an der Stelle einen kurzen Punkt. Ich gucke auf die Uhr, wir machen jetzt gleich Nachrichten. Und danach machen wir weiter am Chaosradio. Wir haben ja noch eine Menge Leute. Habt ein bisschen Geduld, fünf Minuten sind wir gleich wieder da. 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Alexander und Sandra, euch einen schönen Abend.
Live und neu und gut. Fritz empfiehlt. Live im LIDO Berlin. Live im Glashaus in der Arena Berlin Treptow. Wann genau und wo genau?
Fritzee.
Genau. La Rue, The Hilltaboods und Klee Zee. Live von Neu und Gut.
Nachricht.
Genau um halb 12 mit Mario Bartsch.
Bei einem Anschlag in der irakischen Hauptstadt Bagdad sind am Abend mindestens 60 Menschen getötet worden. Nach Angaben der Behörden explodierte die Bomber auf einem belebten Markt. Über 150 weitere Menschen wurden verletzt. Erst am Montag waren in Bagdad mehrere Menschen getötet worden, als ein Sprengsatz neben einem Bus mit Oberschülern explodierte. Das Überleben des insolventen Versandhauses Quelle ist vorerst gesichert. Der Bürgschaftsausschuss von Bund und Ländern einigte sich darauf, Quelle einen Kredit zur Verfügung zu stellen. Der Bund und die Länder Bayern und Sachsen teilen sich das Darlehen von 50 Millionen Euro. Zuvor hatte es der Bund abgelehnt, Quelle eine Bürgschaft zu geben, da das Ausfallrisiko zu groß sei. Die schwedische Internettauschbörse Pirate Bay kommt wieder vor Gericht. Sie wurde von einer niederländischen Copyright-Organisation verklagt. Die drei Gründer von Pirate Bay waren im April zu je einem Jahr Haft und fast drei Millionen Euro Schadenersatz verurteilt worden. Sie hatten über die Webseite links für das kostenlose Herunterladen von Musik, Filmen und Software veröffentlicht. Die deutschen Handballer haben bei der EM 2010 in Österreich eine schwere Vorrundengruppe erwischt. Sie müssen gegen Vize-Weltmeister Polen, gegen Schweden und Slowenien antreten. Da gab es heute die Auslosung in Wien. Die EM findet im Januar statt. Die Fußball-Nationalmannschaft der USA steht überraschend im Finale das Confederation Cup in Südafrika. Der Außenseiter hat das Halbfinale gegen Europameister Spanien mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Der Finalgegner wird morgen zwischen Brasilien und Gastgeber Südafrika ermittelt. Das Endspiel findet dann am Sonntag statt.
Wetter.
Heute Nacht im Süden noch einzelne Schauer und Gewitter, später wechselnd bewölkt und zunächst kaum Regen. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 12 Grad. Der Tag beginnt dann mit Schauern und Gewittern, die von Hoda und Neise herankommen. Es gibt viele Wolken und immer wieder Regen bei maximal 22 Grad. A10, südlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Werder, zwischen Rangsdorf und Genshagen gibt es Fahrbahn-Erneuerungen, deswegen sind dort zwei Spuren gesperrt. A12, Berlin, Richtung Frankfurt-Oder, zwischen Friedersdorf und Storkow liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Besonders vorsichtig dort ist ganz auf der linken Spur. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin, A113, der Zubringer Schönfeld, Stadt Einwärts. Zwischen Adlershof und Spätstraße ist die Autobahn wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Chaosradio auf Fritz, Mittwochabend. Huckel ist hier, Tim ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Twitter und die Twitter Demokratie ist heute unser Thema. Kabel Granz kurz während der Nachrichten gerade in die Tweets gegucken, da ist einer drin, da steht, ich werde irgendwie das Gefühl nicht los, dass sich ein Haufen Leute jetzt nur wegen Chaosradio angemeldet haben. Ob das positiv oder negativ zu werten ist, sei mal dahingestellt. Wenn es aber so ist, dass ihr euch deswegen angemeldet habt, herzlichen Glückwunsch, herzlich willkommen.
Ja, da muss man sich auch nicht so viel Gedanken drum machen.
Ja, aber es ist so, du hast ja immer was.
Ich könnte mir schlechtere Gründe vorstellen, warum man sich bei Twitter anwendet.
Aber es gibt auch was Neues und die Leute, die es schon haben, sind natürlich total dabei, finde ich super. Und je mehr Leute dazu kommen, desto...
Ein bisschen leiser nur mein Kopf hörst.
Also ich finde Twitter skaliert da ganz gut. Da wo das Kabel aus dem Tisch kommt, da ist ein Lautstärkeknopf. Hallo Huckel. Wunderbar geht. Es ist doch eigentlich dann egal, das ist doch so langweilig.
Es gibt auch echt viele Leute, die sich dann anmelden, weil sie halt auch diesen sozialen Zwang spüren und dann aber auch irgendwie gar nichts damit anzufangen, bis man den Account wieder verstauben lassen. Also es ist...
Na so ist das halt.
So ist das halt, genau.
Wir wollten nochmal auf die Follower eingehen und ich hoffe, Christoph ist noch am Telefon, der wartet schon seit fast einer guten Stunde. Hallo Christoph, guten Abend, hier ist Jakob.
So, ich bin dran. Hallo, es piept etwas, hoffe ich nicht.
Nee, aber wir können dich wunderbar hören.
Okay, mein Telefon geht nämlich langsam im Geist auf. Ja, ich bin, ich hab mal vorhin nachgeschaut, tatsächlich schon seit Oktober 07, war dabei, aber ich hab irgendwie die ersten anderthalb Jahre so gut wie nix gemacht, weil ich auch das Gefühl hatte, da tauscht man sich aus, wann man Kaffee trinkt und wann man vorm Rechner sitzt. Aber dann irgendwie kam es, ich glaub auch über Tim, dass es interessant wurde. Und ich hab relativ schnell, weil ich zu Anfang relativ persönliche Sachen mit ein paar Freunden aufgetauscht hab, meinen Account geschlossen gelassen. Also sprich, ich muss bestätigen, wenn mir jemand folgt oder nicht folgt. Und das fand ich auch, hab ich immer noch. Das schränkt mich zwar ein, weil ich wieder gefunden werde durch eine Suche, aber ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl, ich will nicht mit jedem reden. Also ich will auch nicht jedem irgendwie meinen Mist zumuten, in Anführungsstrichen. Und wenn, finde ich es eigentlich sehr nett, wenn ich die Leute irgendwo zumindest durch den Chat oder sonst wie persönlich kenne, da wo, wenn ich den folge, ich glaub auch, dass es irgendwann, ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie man es schafft, mehr als 1000 Leute zu folgen, die einigermaßen aktiv sind. Das rattert dann wahrscheinlich nur so durch. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie glaube ich 40 Leute drauf, die ich kenne, die ich meistens auch persönlich richtig kenne. Das ist schon reichlich, also wenn ich mich abends an den Rechner setze und ich will den Tag über nachgucken, was da getweetet worden sind, oder sind 200 Stück, dann ist das schon eine Menge.
Ja, das ist natürlich so eine Unsitte. Es gibt so Leute, die folgen anderen Leuten und lesen das gar nicht. Das kann man meiner Meinung nach allein schon daran festmachen. Also wenn es eine vierstellige Zahl ist, dann ist das einfach schon mal bekloppt. Und der einzige Grund ist halt der, dass sie einem folgen mit dem Wunsch, selber zurückgefolgt zu werden, um dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, sich toller zu fühlen.
Es gibt auch ganz viele Bots natürlich, die so aggregieren und irgendwie auf jedes Keyword anspringen. Und dann irgendwie, sobald du irgendwas über Apple twitters, hast du dann 23 Apple-Aggregatoren-Bots an der Backe.
Also ich mach das immer so. Also wenn das so offensichtlich Leute sind, die zehnmal so viele Leute folgen wie ihnen folgen, dann block ich die meistens. Es sei denn, es gibt da irgendwie einen besonders guten Grund, aber mir fallen da nicht viele gute Gründe ein, die man haben könnte. Ansonsten eine Alternative zu diesem Problem mit, ich bin oft mal so richtig geschlossen ist man ja auch nicht, wenn man seine Tweets sperrt. Klar, man kommt über das normale Interface nicht rein, aber was ist, wenn du was Cooles sagst und jemand retweetet das? Ja, dann ist es irgendwie genauso offen. Man kann es natürlich auch andersrum machen. Man ist einfach offen, man ist auch suchbar und findbar. Aber wenn man jetzt irgendwie partout irgendjemand nicht permanent immer das Neueste vor die Nase schmeißt, dann blockt man ihn einfach. Kann er zwar theoretisch dann auch noch irgendwie nachschlagen, aber man ist dann schon mal sozusagen, ja, muss man, das ist halt mal wieder, da braucht man so die private Medienkompetenz, da muss man eben selber sehen, wie man damit umgeht. Ist alles in Ordnung.
Also ich fand es ganz interessant, als es für mich interessant wurde, als ich wirklich so Politiker leute, ich meine, ich kenne jetzt lustigerweise auch noch persönlich, ich kann da Volker Beck namentlich nennen, der relativ früh ziemlich aktiv war, der sogar auch für, ich glaube, für von der Rheinischen Post jemand hatte, der mit jemand tatsächlich sonntags irgendwie eine Interview geführt hat über Twitter, das dann in der Zeitung abgedruckt wurde, war so eine ganz lustige Idee. Mit Bütikova fand ich, der hat das auch dazugelernt, der hat am Anfang versucht, wirklich seine Interviews über Twitter zu publizieren, also dass da wirklich so 20 Tweets hintereinander kam, fand ich sehr unangenehm. Mit der Zeit ist er besser geworden, das sind so Sachen, die muss man lernen. Und darüber fand ich eine ganz lustige Sache, dass man so als gewisse, ich hab das zuerst mit Zensula gesehen, dass man sich reingeschrieben hat, irgendwie überschrieben hat, dass man eine gewisse Sympathie zu pflegt oder dagegen diese für die Petition oder jetzt halt mit dem Errat, dass es so ein Tool im Prinzip gab, was das eigene Icon grün gefärbt hat. Fand ich irgendwie eine ganz nette Idee.
Als farblichen Hinweis.
Genau, wenn man auf die Follower geguckt hat von jemanden, so finde ich auch am interessantesten, dass man selber Leute findet, die interessant sind. Wenn man Leute hat, die man selber kennt, dass man guckt, wem folgen die denn? Und dann eben sieht man ganz schnell, dass da irgendwie 20 auf einmal grün gefärbt sind. Und das fand ich irgendwie wirklich eine ganz nette Idee. Ein Aspekt, der mir noch einfällt, was noch überhaupt nicht gedacht wird, das wird ja alles irgendwie gespeichert. Und wie lange wird das aufgehoben, was wir jetzt alle twittern? Weil ich kann nachgucken. Meinen ersten Tweet hab ich nachgeguckt, der tatsächlich irgendwie von Oktober 07 war. Gucke gerade Fernsehen. Das wird mir gelöscht. Ich mein, selbst Google sagt irgendwie, die löschen nach acht Monaten oder neun Monaten. Twitter löscht, vergisst scheinbar gar nichts.
Nö, ist ja bloggen. Aber du kannst es ja selber löschen.
Und dann steht es immer noch im Webarchive.
Ja, und das finde ich halt... Prinzipiell bin ich immer so ein bisschen skeptisch bei diesen Diensten, die nichts kosten. Sodass ich mich irgendwo frage... Ich hab's natürlich irgendwo kapiert. Auch YouTube, ist klar, dass sie irgendwann Geld damit verdienen wollten, tun sie immer noch nicht. Aber so denke ich so ein bisschen, wer weiß, wo das noch alles ausgewertet wird. Also ich will ja nicht die großen Verschwörungstheorien machen, aber irgendwo finde ich es zum Teil schon so ein bisschen fragwürdig, dass das ewig aufgehoben wird.
Ja gut, da kann man ja nur zu sagen, also so ist das, ja. Also wir leben jetzt in der digitalen Welt, da wird kopiert und gespeichert und das Netz vergisst wenig.
Aber Christoph hat schon recht an dem Punkt. Also auch CCC und auch Chaosradio und Chaosradio Express und alle, was immer eine Adresse ist, die sich für Datenschutz ausspricht, für eine vorsichtige Preisgabe von persönlichen Daten. Und dann mit der Huratwitterfahne loszurennen.
Ja gut, aber Datenschutz ist, wie andere mit deinen Daten umgehen. Die Frage ist, wie geht man selber mit seinem eigenen Kommunikationsverhalten um? Ich habe ja genau das gleiche Problem. Ich bin extrem belegbar. Ich denke, man muss da auch einfach dann zu einer gewissen digitalen Aufrichtigkeit übergehen und einfach konsistent sein in dem, wie man ist. Dann ist das auch kein Problem, dass man gespeichert wird.
Aber ist ja irgendwie so ein bisschen die Haltung so, dieses ich hab nichts zu verbergen, also brauche ich nichts zu befürchten, so ein bisschen. Das ist ja eigentlich das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen kann. Warum hast du Angst, wenn deine Telefongespräche gespeichert werden?
Niemand zwingt dich ja dazu, dass du jetzt irgendwie sensitive Informationen oder private Gespräche über Twitter austrägst. Und wenn du das halt machst, dann kann dir halt auch keiner mehr helfen. Die Medienkompetenz, das muss man schon...
Ja, Telefongespräche ist was Privates. Wenn du öffentlich bloggst, und das ist das, was du tust bei Twitter, auch wenn es Microblogging ist, dann tust du das halt öffentlich. Sich dann darüber zu beschweren, dass die Öffentlichkeit das speichert, das hilft natürlich wenig. Wenn du das nicht willst, dann darfst du das nicht benutzen.
Was ich mir vorstellen könnte, was ganz interessant wäre, wenn es so ein automatisches Übersetzungs-Tour gäbe. Also was mir gerade aufgefallen ist, gerade diese arabischen Tweets, die ich jetzt bekommen hab, die ich dann immer bei Google Übersetzung eingegeben hab, das war zum Teil ziemlich schwierig.
Bestimmt im nächsten Twitter-Client mit eingebaut.
Ja, das wäre vielleicht ganz spannend, dass wir so eine universale Sprache dann...
Ja, Google hat sowas schon. Das haben sie ja vor einem Monat demonstriert, als sie da ihr neues Wave-Produkt gemacht haben. Die ziehen tatsächlich ihren ganzen Webindex jetzt auch dazu heran, Übersetzungen zu machen. Das wird glaube ich nicht mehr so lange dauern, dann wird es noch spannender.
Und dann wollte ich noch einen Gruß in Chat loswerden, da ist sehr sehr aktiv, hab ich das Gefühl.
Ja, es rauscht durch.
Danke Christoph. Lade deinen Akku, tschüss.
Ja, der Chat, der rauscht hier.
Ein etabliertes Medium auch, das Irr ist auch nicht totzukriegen.
Da kommt jetzt ein anderer Christoph ans Telefon, der auch eine kritische Stimme zu Twitter hat. Hallo Christoph, guten Abend. Hallo grüß dich. Du sagst, Blogs sind viel schöner, und Twitter ist überbewertet. Warum denn?
Also das Ganze ist jetzt momentan halt ein Hype, weil sehr viele Leute drum twittern. Aber die meisten Tweets, die ich lese, sind eigentlich wirklich nur irgendwelche Links auf, vielleicht lese ich auch die Frage, irgendwelche Links auf irgendwelche Blogs oder irgendwelche News Seiten oder sowas. Und ich weiß nicht, also ich finde, das haben Blogs schon vorher gemacht und auf andere Seiten verlinkt. Und es ist halt mehr so eine Linksammlung, aber da gibt es ja auch, also ich meine, dafür ist es ja nicht gedacht worden.
Aber du hast doch jetzt den Anfang, also die vorherigen Minuten dieser Sendung gehört, oder? Und die ganzen Use Cases, die Nutzungsszenarien hast du ja auch schon gehört. Also dass jetzt eben auch im Iran jemand sein Handy zückt, ein Foto macht, oder eben auch bei der Tempelhof-Besetzung, das ins Twitter schiebt und dann hast du das in deinem Twitter-Kline dieses Foto, bevor es irgendwo sonst ist.
Ja, Moment, aber lass mich die Frage nochmal andersherum stellen. Christoph hat da einen interessanten Punkt angesprochen. Er sagte, alles, was er liest, ist eigentlich eher so, Christoph, korrigier mich weg, je das falsche interpretiere, ist eher so, ich geh jetzt die Straße runter und ich mach mir jetzt eine Pizza und ich sitze da am Rechner.
Er hat gesagt, das sind Links auf Blogs.
Nee, nee, ich hab gesagt, das sind meistens irgendwelche Links.
Oder Links auf Blogs, okay.
Also ich mein, selbst Bilder sind ja nur Links auf irgendwelche anderen Seiten.
Okay, ist die Frage jetzt, wie man interessante Inhalte findet?
Nee, der Punkt ist doch, ist doch egal. Ich meine, das muss man ja gar nicht irgendwie finden. Das schadet der Blogosphäre kein Stück. Ganz im Gegenteil, es ist ein weiteres Medium, über dem Aufmerksamkeit für Blog-Einträge gemacht wird. Blog-Einträge haben einfach eine ganz andere Informationskultur.
Ich wollte damit auch gar nicht sagen, dass ich prinzipiell Twitter schlecht finde. Ich denke nur, es wird jetzt im Moment ein bisschen gehypt und deswegen überbewertet. Also ich denke, wenn dieser ganze Hype, dass jetzt halt sehr viele neue Leute in Twitter kommen, ein bisschen vorbei ist, dann wird es irgendwann eigentlich gar nicht mehr so interessant sein. Also es ist ja schon jetzt so, dass unüberschaubar viele Leute in Twitter sind. Und momentan ist es modern, wenn ein Politiker irgendwie einen Twitter-Account hat und da tweetet. Aber ich meine, wie lange wird es dauern, bis die CDU dann auch langsam erkennt, das ist ein tolles Medium, wo man schön mehr oder weniger auch seine Propaganda verbreiten kann und dann mehr oder weniger da auch...
Aber Christoph, erinnere dich mal...
Get it on, sage ich nur. Ich meine, die werden da ganz schön Schiffbruch erleiden, wenn sie da nichts anderes als Propaganda machen.
Erinnere dich mal an die Zeit, als Webblogs gerade hip wurden, als das irgendwie auch immer mehr explodierte und jeder plötzlich anfing zu bloggen. Das tat ja an sich dem Medium-Blog keinen Abbruch. Ein Großteil der Blogs ist jetzt irgendwie versandet irgendwo so vor sich hin. Aber die lesenswerten Blogs gibt es ja weiterhin und deswegen hat er trotzdem eine Aufmerksamkeit für das Blog an sich geschaffen und so ähnlich wird es auch mit Twitter werden.
Und nicht so auf Twitter als solches versteifen. Wie gesagt, wenn Twitter tot ist, kommt das nächste und das wird noch schneller sein und noch größer und noch mehr vernetzt. Das ist jetzt eine Evolutionsstufe und irgendwann kommt die nächste. Das Sendungsbewusstsein der Leute nimmt ja eher zu als ab. Das glaube ich kann jeder schon mal bestätigen. Und welches Medium sie dann am Ende nutzen?
Also es ist halt so im Moment sind halt hauptsächlich auch wirklich Leute, die sich selber mitteilen wollen in Twitter. Also ich bin da insofern auch keine Ausnahme. Ich schreibe halt alles, was irgendwie ein bisschen, wo ich nur einen Satz oder so dazu zu sagen habe, schreibe ich dann halt in Twitter oder sowas rein, wenn ich irgendwo bin.
Warte, da habe ich noch was.
Ich verstehe nicht so ganz genau, was du jetzt sozusagen eigentlich kritisieren möchtest.
Ich würde sagen, ich finde, man sollte Twitter jetzt nicht unbedingt überwertet werden. Also ich denke, es wird...
Nee, okay, gut, das machen wir jetzt auch nicht.
Dieser Hype, also in jeweil, weil viele Leute sehr begeistert von Twitter sind, auch so im Internet oder so im Freundeskreis und ich finde eigentlich die Tatsache, dass man wirklich nur 140 Zeichen reintun kann, dass man dann nicht mal richtige Links setzen kann, sondern nur URL-Shortener verwenden kann, dass man also auch keine Fotos einbinden kann, sondern zusätzliche Services verwenden kann und dieses ganze komplizierte Drumherum.
Ja, aber offensichtlich hält das die Leute nicht davon ab, das zu benutzen.
Ich finde es ein bisschen kurz. Es kommt doch alles rüber.
Okay, wir haben das jetzt verstanden. Du findest, dass es eigentlich nicht geeignet ist. Ich sag dir, die Leute finden ihren Nutzen dafür und dass das jetzt gehyped wird. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass es so ein Hype-Ministerium gibt, wo dann irgendwas gehyped wird. Das hat ja auch einen Grund, warum das in der Diskussion ist. Darüber reden wir ja hier im Prinzip auch gerade. Das ist da einfach eine Menge Anwendungen dafür.
Wie gesagt, für so Sachen wie jetzt im Iran, finde ich jetzt sehr schön, dass eben da Twitter jetzt eine Anwendung findet. Aber ich denke mal, das ist jetzt momentan so, das wird sich jetzt auch helfen. Immer wenn irgendwo irgendwas passiert, vermute ich mal...
Das passiert schon seit zwei Jahren. Das ist auch nicht nur im Moment so.
Ja gut, vielleicht habe ich es auch noch nicht so mitbekommen, aber ich denke, das wird mit der Zeit die Leute auch irgendwann langweilen, dass man ständig, also dass quasi jeder das jetzt macht.
Okay, die Wette gilt. Ich sage dir, es wird anders sein.
Ich habe ja wie gesagt selber einen Twitter-Account und ich finde es wirklich wahnsinnig unübersichtlich, teilweise da irgendwelche sinnvollen Informationen herauszuziehen. Dementsprechend, da finden wir eben Blogs lieber.
Das ist ja vollkommen okay. Wir sagen mir auch gar nichts gegen. Wir sagen auch nicht, dass du jetzt nur Twitter und nichts anderes benutzen sollst, sondern natürlich alle anderen Medien auch. Das ist ja ganz klar. Und zu diesen 140 Zeichen wollte ich einfach noch mal kurz sagen, das führt halt auch dazu, das habe ich auch erst kritisiert und dachte, nee, das ist ja blöd und wieso. Aber das führt halt auch dazu, dass wirklich jeder Tweet sehr kondens ist, dass die Information sehr dicht ist. Du hast halt nur 140 Zeichen, da musst du jetzt halt auch deinen Punkt rüberbringen und nicht irgendwie bla, Fasel, Blob und drei Zeilen Einleitung, sondern du hast 140 Zeichen, da ist mein Punkt peng, fertig, aus. Und ich finde das halt auch sehr charmant und viele andere eben auch, dass es dazu führt, dass eben die Informationsdichte durchaus auch...
Früher stand an den deutschen Telefonzellen so ein netter Satz.
Fasse dich kurz.
Ich denke nur, das wird irgendwann dann auch sein Ende dann nie mehr in ein, zwei Jahren.
Krisser, wann auch immer, wir können es etwas salopp zumachen und können sagen, es entwickelt sich und wir sind alle mit dabei. Danke dir, schönen Abend.
Imminent Death of the Net predicted, sage ich dazu nur. Kennst du das? Das ist noch so aus den guten alten Tagen, als das Internet noch fast überhaupt niemandem bekannt war und dann so in den Newsnet-Foren, das war sozusagen das erste Twitter, wo sie irgendwie alle waren, wo dann immer mehr kamen und dann permanent die Verrohung und die Versinnlosung der Diskussion angeklagt wurde. Und dann kam halt daraus sozusagen ein eigenes Meme, was unter diesem Begriff Imminent Death of the Net predicted. Also wenn das so weitergeht, dann wird irgendwie alles vorbei sein.
Dann kommt immer was Neues. Also was aber passiert, was wir viele von euch erzählt haben, dass du Twitterst und merkst, es gibt Leute, die haben eine ähnliche Meinung wie du und selbst wenn du dich mit denen nur über welches Medium auch immer erstmal in Kontakt trittst mit dem, um dann irgendwann mit denen vielleicht mal zu telefonieren, um dich dann im wirklichen Leben auch mal mit denen zu treffen. Also wenn das das Resultat ist, was da hinten bei rauskommt, dann herzlichen Glückwunsch, was ein geiles Tool.
Haben wir noch Anrufer?
Haben wir noch. Wir haben noch Oliver am Telefon. Hallo Oliver.
Ein Aspekt, den ihr jetzt schon, oder zwei Aspekte, die ihr kurz angeschnitten habt, die ich kurz mal herausdeuten wollte, ist, für mich hat Twitter mittlerweile fast den Status eines Newsreaders erreicht. Also anstatt mir Feeds in mein NetNews-Wild zu packen oder so, folge ich einfach ein paar Leuten auf Twitter oder auch einigen Blog-Robotern, die automatisch Blogposts in Tweets umwandeln. Und auf die Art und Weise stolpert man über Dinge, die man sonst vielleicht nie gefunden hätte. Seiten, die man sonst nie anschaut, nicht in seinem Newsfeed hat, aber da ist ein interessanter Artikel jetzt zur Iran-Wahl oder zur Zinsursala. Tim, du bist ja auch sehr aktiv und auch über dich habe ich einige interessante Dinge gefunden. Und ja, also man stolpert über sehr viele interessante Dinge. Und die ganzen Dienste, die sich vorher an diesen Punkt versucht haben, was man so diese 20 Icons, die man unter jedem Newspost auf diversen Seiten findet, delicious, dick, yick und wie sie alle heißen, mit denen konnte ich nie was anfangen. Ich weiß nicht, aber das hat mir nie was gebracht.
Geht mir ganz genauso.
Also gab es ja auch hier früher schon mit den Blogs Technorati hatte ja auch mal eine ganz große Hype-Phase, wo dann eben die Blogs da aggregiert wurden und Themen und Trends und haste nicht gesehen. Aber ich habe mich auch schon gefragt, wieso das jetzt bei Twitter eigentlich so anders ist. Aber ich glaube, es liegt auch einfach daran, dass man jetzt halt so Clients hat, wo man halt alles in eine macht. Man kann halt Suchwörter tracken, man hat die Followers. Man kann schön faul sein, sich zurücklehnen und das rieselt so auf einen hinein, ohne dass man noch weiter klicken müsste.
Das ist so Internet-Fernsehen der neuen Generation.
Und ein zweiter Punkt, den ihr auch schon kurz besprochen hattet, Twitter ist ja auch ein wunderbares Werkzeug für das so schön beschriebene Crowdsourcing. Also wenn ich ein Problem habe, wenn ich irgendeine Information suche, wenn mir irgendein was auch immer fehlt, dann blase ich einen kurzen Tweet in die Welt hinaus. Da gibt es ja auch den schönen Dienst LazyTweet. Den könnt ihr vielleicht nachher auch mal kurz erwähnen.
Wir liest noch mal dieses ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin aus Hamburg. Mir fällt es gerade nicht an.
Also ich bin auch so zu Twitter gekommen, tatsächlich, weil ein Kumpel von mir hatte ein Problem hier mit seinem Rechner und hat das irgendwie einfach ins Twitter gehauen und dann hat er irgendwie auch ein paar Minuten später von dem Entwickler von der Software einen Tipp bekommen und dann dachte ich mir, ach so, das kann man nicht nur benutzen für ich gehe jetzt mal baden oder so, sondern man kann da auch richtig dieses Crowdsourcing machen und ich habe selber auch echt schon diverse, unerwartete und ungeplante solche Erlebnisse gehabt, wo ich einfach irgendwie über was gerantet habe und dann kommt halt von irgendwie einem anderen Open Source Projekt einer an und sagt, hier probier doch mal unser Projekt, so ist auch ganz gut. Dann habe ich mir das angeguckt, war super und habe ihm nochmal ein Danke zurückgeschrieben und ohne, dass ich halt irgendwas jetzt groß dafür getan hätte. Also dieses Crowdsourcing ist auf jeden Fall auch ein ganz, ganz großer Punkt, der Twitter für mich irgendwie auch sehr attraktiv macht.
Oliver, dann war's das. Dankeschön. Wir haben noch einen aus, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ruft Markus aus Österreich an. Hallo Markus. Servus, guten Abend. Von wo rufst du an, genau? Ja, jetzt bist du wieder da. Von wo rufst du an? Aus Wien? Okay.
Und ich wollte eure Diskussion zum Schluss noch mal irgendwie aufs eigentliche Thema Twitterdemokratie zurückbringen. Es war jetzt viel die Rede von Twitter allgemein. Und ich hab das Gefühl, also ich hab da letztens einen Tweet gelesen von Philipp Bande und er hat irgendwie geschrieben, 1980 Ökologie, 2009 Internet. Ich fand das sehr treffend. Weil was wir jetzt irgendwie sehen, ist ja das erste Mal, irgendwie kollektive Systeme in die Politik zu halten. Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass wir in ein, zwei Jahren vielleicht gar keine Institutionen wie Parteien verbrauchen werden für politische Prozesse. Also dass wir Systeme wie das Web 2.0, also Systeme des Web 2.0, wie Flickr, Wikipedia etc. jetzt quasi auch in diese Politik hineintragen.
Also ich glaub, Philips Kommentar bezog sich vor allem auf diese aktuelle Diskussion rund um die Piratenpartei, dass halt damals die Ökologie einen großen Teil der Bevölkerung mobilisiert hat, was dann eben zur Gründung der Grünen führte. Und das ist jetzt die bemühte Analogie in Bezug auf die Piratenpartei, die sicherlich auch in vielerlei Hinsicht überhaupt nicht vergleichbar ist mit den Grünen. Aber natürlich dieser Hintergrund, Internet jetzt sozusagen als das neue kulturelle Phänomen, was einfach einem zunehmend größer werdenden Gruppe der Gesellschaft sehr wichtig ist. So wie es eben zu dem Zeitpunkt eben die Ökologie war. Das war sehr wichtig und es war auch so wichtig, dass man gesagt hat, ich unterstütze eine Partei, die jetzt im Prinzip nur, naja, also den Grünen zu unterstellen, sie hätten damals nur ein Thema gehabt. Das wäre auch falsch, weil da steckt ja viel drin. Friedensbewegungen und so weiter. Aber natürlich war Ökologie da ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt. Und ist ja auch heute noch. Und so ist es eben jetzt auch, dass es eine große Gruppe von Leuten gibt, die sagen, uns ist jetzt die Zukunft der Freiheit, der Informationsfreiheit, der Kommunikationsfreiheit so wichtig, dass wir da so einen großen Augenmerk drauf richten und das auch so breit diskutieren, obwohl dadurch andere politische Aspekte vielleicht jetzt gerade mal nicht so im Mittelpunkt der Diskussion stehen, die uns sonst auch wichtig wären. So habe ich das verstanden. Aber mit den Parteien bist du da so sicher, also bin man nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt wirklich der Tod der Parteien ist oder so. Das wird sich glaube ich eher ändern als...
Ja, ich glaube, dass immer mehr politische Entscheidungsfindung vielleicht auch ohne Institutionen möglich sein wird. Durch diese direkte Beteiligung breiter Massen.
Das wäre aber auch schon mal ein Gewinn, wenn man sozusagen überhaupt in deren Entscheidungsfindung damit eingreifen könnte, was derzeit eigentlich nur dadurch möglich ist, dass man selber da drin ist.
Und da hab ich das Gefühl, dass die Parteien das noch nicht verstehen.
Wie ist denn das mit Twitter eigentlich in Österreich? Wir haben jetzt viel über deutsche Debatten gesprochen.
Es gibt eine extrem aktive Gemeinde, insbesondere hier im Wiener Raum. Ganz spannende Diskussionen jetzt gerade hier im Wiener Kontext zum Thema Grüne Landespartei, die irgendwie laut ihrer Statuten eine sehr basisdemokratische Ausrichtung haben, wo festgehalten ist, dass jeder, der sich offen zu dieser Partei bekennt, auch an dieser Partei, in dieser Partei mitarbeiten darf. Das hat jetzt eine große Gemeinde hier in Wien. Hauptsächlich wird Twitter sehr ernst genommen und sich organisiert und wollte da jetzt irgendwie für die kommenden Parteiversammlungen ein Stimmrecht erlangen. Wurde dann aber sehr schnell abgeschmettert von dieser Partei, von Teilen dieser Partei, die wohl irgendwie Angst haben, dass über diese Bewegung die Partei übernommen wird.
So wie damals die FDP in Berlin.
Und die einfach noch nicht verstehen, welche Chance sich da auftut durch die Beteiligung, die jetzt einfach möglich wird durch diese widerschwellige Chance.
Ich greife mal dein Wort auf und sage, Chancen, die entstehen, da sind wir gerade Zeuge der Entwicklung, was mit Twitter und vielen anderen Feeds gerade passiert, welche Kommunikationsmittel sich bieten durch das Netz, durch Web 2.0 dadurch, dass du mit Leuten kommunizieren kannst, ohne auf einen bestimmten Punkt einen Rechner oder eine Kneipe oder was angewiesen zu sein. Wahrscheinlich ist das alles nur der Anfang von dem, was da irgendwann mal kommt und wir bleiben weiterhin gespannt. Markus, dir schönen Gruß nach Wien und schönen Abend noch. Wir müssen jetzt nämlich echt die Segel streichen, weil gleich kommt Tobi Koch mit Night Flight. Das war's Chaos Radio auf Fritz zum Thema Twitter mit Huckel und Tim. Chaos Radio Express, nächstes Thema, Tim? Mach noch ein bisschen.
Das nächste Thema? Ich kündige normalerweise meine Themen im Vorfeld nicht an. Das ändert sich genau heute. Die nächste Thema ist Tech.
Und hier noch eine andere Ankündigung im CCCB. Also im Chaos Computer Club Berlin findet morgen, glaube ich, ein Datengarten statt, auf den ich hier hinweisen sollte. Das findet ihr auch noch mal auf berlin.ccc.de. Und als Abschlusswort hier nochmal, hätte ich ja auch gerne nochmal das hier eingespielt. Jetzt müsste der Chat hier explodieren.
Vielen, vielen Dank für eure Anrufe. Noch mal hören geht entweder auf fritz.de oder aber auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Da steht der Podcast dieser und auch von allen anderen Sendungen. Wir hören uns dann spätestens in vier Wochen wieder zum nächsten Chaos Radio hier gleich an Neidfeld auf Fritz. Tschüss, tschau, bis bald.